welcome everybody to the beautiful city
of saint louis we are back in the
central west end at the saint louis
chess club this time with the first
round of the 2015 singfield cup some of
the players are just arriving here at
the club it's going to be a very
exciting event and for more information
we go to the studio with jen and yas
thank you alejandro i'm jennifer shahady
i'm here with grandmaster yasser sarwan
and we are so thrilled to be with you
for the next two weeks to cover the
second event on the grand chess tour and
the third ever
2015 sink field cop absolutely jenna's
great back to be here in st louis with
you and maurice and i am looking forward
to an historic
uh championship tournament here this is
going to be a fantastic event yeah
absolutely let's take a look at the
pairings i i don't know what i'm more
excited about the fact that this is the
third sink field cop or the second leg
of the grand chess store but it's huge
look at the pairings gary versus grisha
so versus
oronion versus last year's torture
fabiano caruana
world champion magnus carlson he's
playing against bethlehem topalov and
finally
nakamura versus vishyanan
thrilling matchups and
we're going to actually go to
grandmaster maurice ashley who's also
going to be with us every day here at
the grand chess tour for the key match
ups today yay
well this is an incredible tournament
naturally it is something we all dream
about watching the top players in the
world vying for a top tournament the
singfield cup well the matchups are
great anan and nakamura battling that's
a superstar matchup of course but the
one we're going to keep our eye on is
the one between carlson and topalov we
remember from norway what happened when
carlson and they these they last saw
each other
carlson had the white pieces he was on
his way to victory and then oops he
forgot the time control of all things
and he ended up losing on time we see
here a disgusted carlson showing how he
was in fact winning topolov of course
thank you very much for the gift point
he went on to win the event but all of
norway was in shock as their wonderkid
and their world champion lost in the
very first round of the event and he
went on to have a terrible tournament
just something that you can't expect
from him uh not at this tournament i'm
picking him to win in this event and i
think he's going to start off strong you
know he's got revenge on his mind in
this the first round of the sink field
cup
i absolutely agree magnus carlson today
will be out for blood so we'll be
keeping a close eye on that match up
let's also take a look at the grand
chess tour standings which were
beautifully set up in norway well not so
beautifully set up according to magnus
carlsen our world champion who's only
got four tour points and a lot to make
up for
here in st louis
but vessel and topalov wow he's got 13
tour points
that's the best start he can hope for
absolutely vishy and on right behind her
and nakamura are also in good standing
and playing very well this year so we
expect good things from him
yuri with seven points also within
striking distance
and vashir lagrav with five now notice
guys hammer at the bottom with one point
not really been anyway because he was
the wild card for that event so he won't
be playing
in st louis or london but really
exciting news for american fans is we do
have wesley sew as the wild card here
and
that kid just plays really exciting
unpredictable chess and
it'll be fun to have him in this field
without question and again
when you think about eight of the top
ten players in the world playing in the
event the three wild cards wesley sow
hammer and mickey adams of all three
events on rating on paper this will be
the strongest and therefore the
strongest 10 player field
ever held
that's right so wesley so i mean isn't
it exciting to be an american chess fan
right now where our wild card and our
third highest ranked player is still in
the top ten exactly that is absolutely
incredible and that of course is wesley
so because we've got nakamura and
caruana who are ahead of him exactly
three americans in the field uh
it's extraordinary when i was growing up
it was a soviet-dominated
uh
time and you would have many many
russian players in this field only one
russian player alexander grishok that's
right alexander grisha new to st louis
um he hasn't participated in either of
the other thing field cups but of course
he surely was watching very closely um
the other two events as um was gary so
it was exciting to see how happy they
are to be in st louis and playing in
this event yesterday at the opening
ceremony during the q a uh moderated by
maurice uh
he was asked maurice asked alexander
grishock how did it feel to be in st
louis and he said that he's been a fan
of our show
and that he's looking forward to maurice
saying and alexander grishrook has big
attack a big attack against us that's
right it's always it was very humorous
he said maurice is his absolutely
favorite weather man so
there we go we'll be we'll be looking
for some hot weather from alexander
grisha now we see uh geary seated at the
board um you'll notice these uh um
attractive water bottle is actually a
sponsor of uh
the event yeah the grandchild store
that's the norwegian water exactly oh
yeah
so
oh and here he is the world champion
rematch first vessel and top love you
know they both know the time control
this time
and
vaseline you know had to take the point
it's the rules of chess but magnus
carlsen really is um out for it in this
game wow the chess club is so packed
this year it's just incredible because
last year it was pretty busy but i think
this this year it's just doubled or
tripled in size the crowd without
question 300 people were waiting in line
for the autograph session yesterday by
the way and it was uh
it's thrilling as a player to have a
packed house you just love playing to a
packed house i am looking forward to
an incredibly combative tournament i
think the the
crowds will bring out the best in the
players and let's go to tony richie
executive director of the club for the
official opening
hello everyone and welcome to the 2015
sing field cup round one i'm tony rich
the executive director of the chess club
and scholastic center of st louis and it
has been my pleasure to organize the
event along with the fantastic team of
of employees contractors vendors
and i hope that the spectators enjoy the
show that we put on here
we have the top 10 players in the world
competing over the next two weeks to
ultimately win the coveted sink field
cup
leg 2 of the grand chess tour
it's my pleasure now to introduce the
chief arbiter of the event international
arbiter chris byrd we'll have a couple
of announcements for the spectators and
players and then we'll let the action
begin
chris
thank you very much
um okay some quick announcements for the
spectators since we're still missing a
couple of the players
um spectators once again you're welcome
to come up here at any time during the
round while the play is going on we must
ask you to remain completely silent once
you get past the security checkpoint
downstairs
once you're past that you're to remain
silent there's no whispering no talking
anywhere on this level of the of the
facility please
again with cameras you're welcome to
take photographs at all times during the
round
flash photography during the first 10
minutes only
media you'll be allowed in within the
plane area for the first five minutes
and then um i'll ask you to step out and
go behind the stanchions
um players one quick announcement for
you
you'll all be very pleased to know that
the confession booth is up and running
we did soundproof that and get that
completely
checked at least to my um
you know i approved it this morning so
we're good to go on that um you will
see a little room in the kitchen that
says either it's available or in use
if it says available feel free to go in
there and
spill out whatever you would like to
talk about
and then once you finish with that room
then make it available for the next
person to use
i'd like to um welcome up here uh rex
and jeannie sinkfield
um if you would like to come over here
please i'd like one of you to come and
uh do the
regular ringing of the bell to to enable
us to start the round jean is going to
come over here
thank you very much
let me ask my assistant if she could uh
bring me the bell please
okay don't ring it yet
yeah
and here we have our final play
again for the spectators just quickly
remember you've got um a couple of other
facilities where you can go and enjoy
some of the chess action um right down
here at the kingside diner there's live
commentary across the street at the hall
of fame they're going to be doing live
commentary of course you can come up
here and come and watch the action live
you've just
got to remain really quiet
i think with that said
and all the players are here
i think we're ready to go
ginny if you do the honor
good luck and go ahead and start white's
clock please
we are started
and we've got a knight f3 by wesley so
against maxine vashir
one of the exciting things about wesley
soh in all of his matchups in this
tournament is we haven't seen as many
iterations right you know
nakamura and anand have played what nine
times a lot of these players have faced
each other numerous news yeah exactly
especially when you count the rapid
games whereas uh wesley is a bit of the
x factor here now um of course for
fabiano caruana one of the sore points
of the zoroa chess tournament was he's
lost levon oroneon and pretty much the
only positive for levon
exactly and that'll be a big uh game uh
in terms of settling their accounts for
uh their own individual scores as well
as getting the tournament underway but
this is what we all want to see magnus
carlsen has played e4
and bishop b5 check against the najdorf
so a kind of uh
saying i'm not going to play into any
heavy theoretical lines but this bishop
b5 shack has really gained a lot of
popularity against the night or as the
night earth has done so well in the main
lines
knight d7 instead of bishop d7 which is
considered the
the safe way of getting uh equality uh
knight d7 right right we got the the
famous was wasn't that the famous uh
gary kasparov against the world match
where he was gets a little bit upset
when people used to play bishop b5 tech
yes because he didn't think it was
testing math but it turned out to be one
of the great games wasn't it that was uh
microsoft's
match now here in the in this moment
let me just bring this game up on my
screen by the way
black could play the move a7 a6
attacking this bishop on b5 provoking
this trade bishop takes bishop takes but
the thing is that after d4 pawn takes
queen takes d4
with the knight on c6 missing the queen
takes up a very nice station in the
middle of the board
and
the theory considers that white has the
upper hand as early as the seventh move
so unless vessel is going to do
something a little bit different let me
pardon me i just put this position back
on our screen you could first toss in
the move knight gf6 and in case of
knight c3 a small difference here
but it could be an important one
over that line i just showed
is that now this knight on c3 sits in
front of the c2 pawn and white doesn't
get that moroccy buying position that a
lot of black players try to avoid so
early
things happening
but key subtle things are happening in
this the first round match up between
magnus carlson and vessel and top law
right now and if black can get g6 and
bishop g7 in here then that would be a
very merry situation
uh it always depends upon these tactics
yes exactly with e5 and bishop g5 bishop
g5 bishop g7 well e5 yes but this also
is kind of a little bit annoying move
knight d5 yeah blackhead just has to be
careful that this square b6 doesn't end
up being a sore spot in his position
shall we just take a little uh
let's go to maurice actually because
maurice had something that he wanted to
share
maurice uh
as he's getting his position all set up
well these players have played this
before they played in tata steel in 2012
and there was a spectacular game in this
exact same line carson of course plays
the move bishop b5 quite often as a
matter of fact and so this is coming as
no surprise to topple off especially
after losing that particular game the
opening did go 97 c3 knight gf6 queen e2
a6
bishop to a4 and then queen c7 not the
main move but actually scoring quite
well in this position that game was
absolute chaos we might go into that
line a little bit later on but certainly
tepalav knew quite well that he might
see this position and so he's well
prepared for bishop to b5 check from
magnus
thank you maurice and uh a game that's
just been going gangbusters my goodness
fabiana
cariwanna black against lavona roni and
the queen's gambit declined the players
have just blitzed out a a large number
of moves
both players
saying hey i'm well versed in this
position
and look at them go it's not a blitz
match but they sure have played their
opening very very quickly well fabiano
said it last year he sees no point in
feigning ignorance if he knows what he's
going to play if he's looked at it at
home he just tosses out the moves
immediately
and sometimes people just out of
you know
i don't know what the word would be like
uh routine they like to think a little
bit before each move but he's like hey
i've analyzed this i'm just going to
count it out
well we saw that a lot last year and
the only negative of that is that
that means that he's a point we'll know
when he's no longer analyzing position
true that okay well let's see what just
happened in that game between lavon roni
and white
uh fabiano cariawanna black
they played a conventional queens gambit
declined bishop e7 and then bishop f4
very very popular move don't get me
wrong but
historically speaking bishop g5 has been
the preference of most grand masters
bishop f4 is a little bit more of a
modern twist now remember that in a
norway chess lavon actually played the
english and uh didn't end up getting
that much actually he won the game but
fabi was doing quite fine right out of
the opening and middle game no question
about it okay so this move c4 c5
is an attempt to try to get a grip over
here on the queen side
as well as
now that this bishop on f4 is pointing
on this diagonal if i can get that uh
it would work very well except black has
a counter punch
94
brook c1 trade
b7 b6 trying to loosen up white's
control over the c5 pawn if white wants
he can play b2 b4 and usually after this
move b4 then c7 c6 with the id of a5
tries to put as much pressure as black
can on these b4 and c5 pawns
instead
what happened
was that uh let me just go back here for
a second and said c6 was played c5 c6
which really puts a cr
a cramp
on this bishop on c8 black has to be
worried that this bishop on c8 doesn't
get uh developed
and after that came
to stopping the pin right a2 a3 exactly
as you say stopping the pin
but also threatening very
importantly threatening b4
and this bishop will be a prisoner for
the rest of the game
so very quickly a7 a5 was played and
then do we have more moves uh jen um it
looks like we do uh fabi has afternoon
i think he played knight e4 and f6 okay
so yeah it's interesting you know this
move c5 you don't see it in
that many d4 openings but i think one of
the reasons here that it's effective is
because that bishop on f4 stops another
counter play idea of white playing black
playing e5 e65 right
so okay um
completing his development bishop d3 or
preparing to complete his development
nighty force uh taking the square he's
gotta get some counter play here as
black and he has played for this idea of
getting e5 in
and that's that's critical because you
know the thing is when there's a pawn on
c4 it's hard to get that idea e5 in
because there's always like takes on d5
bishop c4 ugliness
so i think this makes a logical sense
but whoa
what about the uh well for if i if i
were black i would really really be
worried that my bishop on c8 would be
incarcerated for the rest of the game so
you'd be trying to play bishop a6 oh you
know it uh bishop a6 would be my
instantaneous move and then like you say
trying to uh maneuver and get this break
in f7 f6 would be a secondary
consideration
uh whether he was worried about
something tactical after bishop takes it
doesn't it doesn't seem like that loose
rook on a six um
it's like
anything yeah i could i'm just looking
for combinations of queen d3 and 95 but
oops excuse me i'll drop back with the
room
knight e5 well
okay we always have that that square
um the thing i think is like i was maybe
sometimes we have some sacrifices with
knight b6 and c7 but probably not right
so you get a tempo down here against the
rook and then you're thinking well if i
can ever unleash the power of the passer
but that wasn't played and that's why i
said
this is
a
very
um you find it risky huh risky play he's
a reasonable taking an e4 or something
or not no the reason i find it risky is
that after the move queen e2
permanently preventing the bishop from
ever going to a6 essentially black is
obliged one day to play e6 and e5
liberating this bishop but can he get
that break in when white covers the e5
square like four times i can only
imagine g5 g5
bishop g3
h5 which is really a kind of a bridge
burning move
uh
is what fabiano has in mind
but it really really does there's a lot
of sacrificial ideas or you could just
you know perhaps move the knight back to
d2 um aiming to capitalize on the white
squares that you just uh
handed to me
they made permanently weak right good
luck taking on yeah exactly you could
take one you could play h4 but i was
thinking here that this is going to be
quite dangerous yeah without question
because even
after for example h takes g3 h takes
place
yeah exactly that rook is uh ideally
positioned to
make further operations against white's
black's king site so strategically
speaking a very
sharp
uh position has suddenly occurred right
out of the opening here and
lavon ironian is wondering
did
is this all preparation by fabiano or
did he just make
a finger failure an error
not to play that move bishop a6 i'm
guessing i'm guessing it was prep
because all these lines look so
dangerous for black that somebody of
fabiano's carolina is not if he plays
the move f6 quickly
there's no way he's going to play it
quickly if he hasn't analyzed it at home
it's just it's as you say too bridge
burning yes makes sense but again after
the queen e2 basically isn't black
challenged to play the move g5 because
if you allow white for argument's sake
to just play h3 and castles this bishop
will be permanently
sidelined it will be out of the game
right so once again let's just give that
a quick look
and keeping in mind that fabiano is uh
here to defend his title maybe f5
instead playing for f5 rather than
because h5 looked kind of awful you mean
f5 now yeah
well you are like giving up this e5
squad yeah i was trying to play f4 but
you're just gonna
oh
i mean if you play knight e5 i can play
f4 right
and
well it's not they i'm not sure i think
this is it doesn't it looks like
beginner chess moving on my pawns and
not developing any pieces i would say
i'm trying to
you're cruising for a bruising is what i
would the way i would put that
because after for example a check i'll
pick up this yeah
yeah
it's not a happiness
but
maurice we've got a conundrum here has
uh fabiano fallen into a
strategically
um
wobbly situation or not this is wild
if he has fallen into it is because he
stepped into it on purpose
it looks as though this line has been
well prepared by him it's hard to
believe that he did not have this on his
chest board or chest screen at home at
some point we know he comes up with
original analysis all the time first of
all let's go to the reference games he
played this twice against no other than
anand and giri in fact this year he
played it against giri in tata steel he
had draws in both of those games but he
played more traditionally there in this
position after a5 those players played
rook c2 against him and the same
position occurred though with bishop to
d3 there he went after bishop a6 so this
time clearly he's played it twice
clearly he knows that whoever is going
to play against him will know those two
games those are famous games this is a
line that he himself prefers with the
move uh b6 and a5 the knight e4 line
we've seen so here this was the kind of
position they transposed to get to the
same position here with bishop d3 first
then 94 rook to c2 f6 his novelty in his
position it's certainly his his choice
here to play queen e2 bishop to d6 and
this is why aronian is now on pause
because he no doubt knew about those
other two games and here fabiano as he
seems to do and he's as he certainly did
last year he blitzed out his moves and
showed his great preparation and he's
still on it look at that g5 now on the
board playing wicked chess fabiano
carrana revisiting the craziness he
played but the sense of purpose he
played with last year at the sink field
cup so he's starting off this tournament
with a bang right away
wow
bishop d6 was the computer-generated
move the suggestion and instead he has
played what you and i were looking at
and saying the human moves g5 because
it's the most forcing but i
aesthetically i preferred bishop d6 once
mario
okay so
obviously the bishop under attack the
bishop is going to step back but having
said a
what is the b or do you mean after age
how do you follow up with a move like g5
at the moment white hasn't committed
himself to castling king's side yet and
it you know from my eyes uh fabiana has
made some serious a bridge burning on
his skin so i've got some ways to
consolidate the situation but we've got
g5 in another position
i'll be really curious to see what
fabiano has up his sleeve because he has
prepared this but let's go look and see
the other g5 by vessel and topology no
way he's played it against magnus
carlsen in the bishop
b5
sicilian this is not something you see
every day uh not exactly
but some kind of okay so he after
castles which is where we left the game
magnus castle knight f6 magnus played
the natural move rookie looking all
classical and chill both players ready
to develop and this is where we said a6
putting the question to the bishop now
we were
now we would have expected the world
champion to drop his bishop back to f1
he chose the d3 square
which
blocks the pawn on d2 and it isn't
intuitively very attractive no i mean
sometimes you can remaneuver it to c2
with c3 and then play d4
but the thing about that is um you know
black might be able to respond to that
with a fiance and then the bishop's
scope on that b1 h7 diagonal is really
nothing to write home about okay
so bang
b
7
b5 so one of the ideas that topolof has
is he could chase this bishop with c4
and put his bishop on b7 so
magnus said c2 c4 i'm going to attack
your b-pawn
and so topolof said well if you want it
you can have it
g5
okay that's it i mean i don't think
there's any reference games for this
move i could well be wrong but let's
just take this pond
let's eat it well hold on you're the
pawn grabber i will grab the pond of
course but only after a 20 minute thing
maurice what the heck is g5 well we got
to go into the database to find this
stuff and really look at it and i
brought up chess base here to take a
look and if you look at this line let me
just give give us a little extra room if
i can here okay i'm going to leave it
alone for now i'll set that later but
just take a look at this board this this
position has been seen before even with
the funky looking move bishop to d3
we've had gotokomsky himself played with
the white pieces uh other other players
as well but nakamura with the black
pieces here played the move b5 so so far
so good no problem the most popular move
here to deal with the threat of c4 for
black was the move c4 for white so so
far so good we've seen this before
now as i look i see knight d seven to e5
i see takes on c4 i see b4 i see rook b8
i see bishop b7 i see a lot of natural
moves what i don't see as a choice is
this one g5 you see everything go white
over here everything on this side went
whoa what's going on never been played
g5
what a move and you know carlson is
going
what are you doing
this has gotten exciting and and uh
topolov's saying it might have been luck
the last time i beat you but i'm coming
to get me a world champion today you see
the jacket has come off also for carlson
magnus carlson having to go into a deep
think as this game is heating up as well
as the other one with g5 certainly a
great start to the sink field cup
i'm just checking my watch for 15
minutes into the round and we have two
wild games going on g7 g5 whoa come on
what can we say i'm an old pawn grubber
let's let's go i've been waiting for you
to actually take that one
no knight takes g5 okay so the first
thing
uh i i have to consider is that knight
e5 will be a double attack against my
bishop and pawn
as well as the move rook g8 what should
i get in first let's let's start with 95
because it's a kind of a natural
you know uh continuation
now we got to move our bishop or defend
it so what are we going to do jen drop
it back yeah i don't think we want to
give up that bishop especially with the
diagonal
true that means you can take the pawn
back that and
maybe that's the big uh big idea for
topalov that he's simply going to be
able to take back on c4 at some point
right so you could have interpolated
taking on b5 perhaps but then maybe g4
was an issue
i think that's something else to analyze
yeah we'll come back to that one so rook
g8 if we're going to sacrifice the g
pawn let's try to exploit what we hope
will be the half open g file
now
essentially white could fall into a
pretty annoying pin here
uh imagine if he was to drop back
immediately probably he should play d2d3
yeah and then this move bishop g4 could
suddenly
uh there's play in this position
suddenly for black this is no fun yeah
yeah if i were three if i were white i
would have feel like i've lost the
initiative so let me toss out the move
f2 f4 which uh does two things it
defends the knight on g5 it attacks the
knight on e5 we'll capture a pawn back
yeah although you still you also should
probably analyze the in-between move
bishop g4 after f4 okay
if that helps or hurts although
is this one of those situations where we
can actually look at no that's a lovely
uh tempo gainer
the thing that i was going to i was
trying to seize the initiative i'm
actually giving back some material in
this particular line bishop takes e2
queen takes e2 knight takes
now the whole point here is maybe that
king still stuck in the middle
might give me a sh g might give me a
chance
to try to take advantage of my
superior development
so that i'll just show one line where
vessel and had better be uh careful
there's an e5 e6 in the position that
this is a wildlife yeah well no it's not
even okay yeah this is just beautiful
right now oh you're so sure though well
i mean imagine queen shack
okay where are you gonna go with your
king
i
so i could play b3 but then you can
capture on e5 precisely yeah so if i
play king h1 then
i'm seizing a counter attack knight g4
threatening to come down here with
knight f2 check
and uh
true and if i play and if i just play
rook to f1
then i've got the e5 well i don't have
the e5 pawn right away
yeah that's true rook f1 protects the f2
pawn now i can grab this pawn on e5 but
this is messy that looks very messy and
let's go back i was even thinking after
bishop g4 i was looking for ways to try
to sacrifice a queen with takes on e5 it
doesn't seem like it quite works
oh you may get uh further further down
the road yeah but oh no no no um after
after f4 bishop g4 f takes e5 i guess
just bishop d1 takes on f6 it doesn't
seem like
oh
oh i see oh you
you're partying with the ladies you got
to look at these things but anyway let's
let's so bishop g4 is a possibility but
you wanted to show me another line well
no i think that bishop g4 does make a
great deal of sense in fact and i liked
your move but i was going to say that
knight takes without bishop g4 pardon me
there was this move knight takes and i
was going to go d2 d3 just kind of
picking up a tempo i want to push this
knight to
rotten square and then i was going to
follow up with e5 a lot of exciting
things we're doing something wrong hope
oh i hope so
for for for magnus because okay
can we refine can we try taking on b5
first i don't think so but i just wanted
to double check let's do that let's take
on
although this feels wrong for a while
black has this in between move g4
precisely and now now the knight doesn't
have a good square the knight on
the the squares d4 the natural squares
d4 and e5 are covered i think you're
going to have to go like
you're going to go to something
okay but it's messy oh geez
and i've got a feeling that if i well
for sure
so much by the way why do i hate knight
h4 because i guess yeah i don't really
i'm strong i'm just thinking that the
knight is
yeah it just doesn't make a
a pleasing impression benko gambit
players might
and benoni players might find this
attractiveness if i could play knight f5
to e3 it'd be okay but you're gonna get
e6 in um maurice ashley um your thoughts
on this kerfuffle
kerfuffle this is uh
quite a kerfuffle let's just
leave it like that
man this game is crazy and the problem
i'm looking at this with a database and
you know magnus is joe cool so he's
trying to act like yeah you know so uh
you just played g5 i'm a little bit
bored let me stretch but he is starting
to realize the situation that he's in
and that this move g5 is a legitimate
move that is scary and if you start
looking at this with the engines you
realize just how scary it is well let's
start with this line with knight takes
g5 knight to e5 is what the engines
really like here attacking the bishop
attacking the pawn and you can't do
anything like say let me be greedy and
keep it because all of a sudden comes
this move eight six what are you gonna
do with your knight where are you gonna
put it you put it here we snap it with
the bishop knight's coming into f3 if
you put it here then we take that anyway
knight takes f3 g takes f3 rook g8 and
now your king is funny a bishop is going
to show up on h3 and we all know this
kind of attack from great school we saw
how you could come at a king quite
directly so this itself is very very
dangerous for white you could keep
looking at it with the engines these are
already saying he's busted g5 let's go
back to this knight takes g5 knight to
e5 well if you just drop back your
bishop e2 or or f1 either move
the move is going to be b takes on c4
this position might be a reasonable way
for white to play drop the knight back
now to f3 and look to see if you can get
something there the engines are saying
here that white does have a bit of a
positional edge i would bet that this is
where white goes if it's magnus he's
going to figure out how to tamp down the
energy in the position instead of just
trying to refute the move again back to
this move
g5
if you don't take so this was the
critical question you guys asked if you
take on b5 instead well here comes g4
and now it gets completely while e5
doesn't work well e5 is possible takes
knight to g5 though as the next move
instead of knight takes of course
because of knight takes rook takes and
thank you very much for that free bishop
on d3 so knight g5 a suggestion there
looks quite unusual uh if you don't play
e5 though and you play knight h4 yes yes
after e6 as you mentioned jen this move
just shuts the knight on this side what
pawn are we down you know if you play
the banco the benoni if you just play
aggressively as black you love the fact
that this knight is stranded this pawn
is irrelevant black has tremendous play
he's already thinking about trapping
this knight and don't weaken this square
uh trying to defend it with g3 because
this knight is ready to hop in as well
so lots of chances here it looks as
though
topolov has prepared this extremely well
maybe the world champ is uh in trouble
but i think that
objectively speaking he will play for
the solid line magnus does not like to
grab pawns like you yes unless it's
clear to him that he's just winning if
he takes it i think he's searching for a
positional line like we mentioned before
with
with uh takes
uh and bringing the bishop back to e2
and and trying to go that route guys
thank you maurice and let's not forget
that uh vessel and topalov former world
champion when he won his world
championship he did it
in style i mean he was the dominant
player in san luis and he brought in
this incredibly aggressive dynamic play
with both colors and we're seeing it
here today maybe we're seeing the best
of vessel and topolof as of course he's
also our grand prix
grand chester tournament leader i mean
and look at him with
bearing down
naturally when the webcam he's bearing
down and
magnus does not see
at this moment a clear way of just
diffusing or tapping down the energy
that
um vessel has brought to this game
that's right so we got a huge crowd
around these two
fighters and
we should remind everyone that topolov
is tied for second in the world in the
2700 chess live rankings right now so he
and vishy an inspiration to all 40 year
olds all over the world that's right now
let's take a look at the breakdown of
how you get points in the grand chess
store
because um that's that's what they're
going for they're going for a winning
single account but also trying to win
the grand chess tour so you earn points
based on your final standing in each
event players with the most tour points
at the end of the grand chess tour earn
bonus prize manny and of course bragging
rights for winning the first of this
exciting competition first place is 13
points if you win clear like vaseline
did in norway and 12 points if you tie
and you end up winning in a playoff
um second is ten points third is eight
four seven all the way down for one
point for a tenth place replacement
and let's see what they're playing for
in both the stingfield cup and in the
grand chess tour well in the event we've
got 75k for first um second is 50k
and all the way down to 15k for 10th
place
however there's also more to play for
bonus prizes first place in the grand
chess store which we'll conclude in
london will be 75 000
additional and second will be 50 and
third will be 25.
so lots of cash to play for lots of
bragging rights and lots of radiant
points uh we'll
keep a close eye on this and guys
remember to share your own thoughts and
tweets with us at the hashtag
singfieldcop
as
we begin a thrilling competition and a
great way to kick it off with two early
g5s in the opening right we love that
maurice
wow i just took a look at another line
that is completely insane just like you
like to play them yes
take a look at this position between
aronia and karwana this is just sick i
mean right now it is black to move the
engines are saying the position is 0.00
yeah right whatever that means
this position black could play the move
g4 i mean he's already loosened that
king side why don't we loosen it some
more after g4 knight to d2 and now the
move e5 let's open up the game when you
have a lead in development what about
those classical rules being broken
now the move e4 just instant like why
not let's break the position open since
you want to open it yourself look at
these pawns a massive
cluster
all kinds of calculations and
computations to be made
which one do we take how about we not
take and introduce yet another pawn into
the game f5 this is just chaos here way
too much to calculate well let's see
what happens if we take this point your
knight's under attack what are you going
to do about it let's ignore it and take
upon attacking your bishop this is best
lined by the engine by the way crazy
chess is what you could call it that'll
probably be an understatement take
knight take bishop hitting the queen
queen takes it now queen takes d6
finally we get a chance to breathe as
all the tension is gone right here out
of the middle of the board but black is
threatening bishop to f5 very quickly so
queen to d4 hiding from that now bishop
f5 springing to the action rook back and
now rook 88 and now you start looking to
go
black ain't bad i mean the c6 ball looks
like it'll need protection for a long
time the king looks fine even though
it's a little bit airy
chaos has suddenly settled down into
more p kind of a peaceful position with
black having a lot of energy so it looks
as though karana should be fine in this
line and in the meantime on the other
board where g5 occurred we see magnus
carlsen struggling and maybe getting
into dare we say
time pressure he's heard that before
losing on time back in norway and he's
got to figure out what to do in this
position where clearly
his opponent has prepared this
spectacular move
thank you maurice for summing that up so
very well i'm stunned that
in the game between a lavon aronian and
fabiana he was able to just suddenly
compress the position i thought that
white looked really really good if there
was an argument i would have with levon
it would be his last move rook e1 that
makes this whole g4
followed by e5 maneuver possible in the
first place
i would want to play the move e3 e4
myself
and if i thought the immediate e4 g4 was
a little bit unclear i would probably
have simply started i like my knight on
f3 because it restrains this e75 and i
really like playing e2
e3 e4 you know when i'm ahead in
development trying to open up the game
and whatnot but
levon did play the move rookie one
pardon me let me just go back there
oops
okay
i'll get the position just a second uh
bishop takes knight takes rookie one was
played and this was a wild line and it
it had a very
forcing nature to it g4 attacking the
knight well you don't want to put it on
the side you want to keep it in the
center knight d2 e5 e4
and that move f5
whoa wow definitely that's a remarkable
move it requires uh some home home
preparation that's it that's what it
requires home preparation do not do this
without careful careful uh preparation
and
impressive i mean just an applause for
great preparation by fabi and last year
when he had such a remarkable
storied
result it was in fact due to some great
preparation that was that was a big part
of it um
and anish giri actually mentioned
watching fabiano carolina's result last
year and what was most remarkable to him
was that fabiano won in almost every
different way you could imagine yes
with a beautiful sacrifice based on some
great preparation like against topalov
with um some great preparation that led
to
a beautiful grind against iranian with
you know just a tactical
chaos that he ended up on top of against
carlson he's just like one game after
another was always something a little
different yes yes it seemed like he won
in every conceivable way right and by
the way fabiano didn't go for the moves
g4 and e5 which i could not find fold
with instead he has played the move a
five a4
just making sure that white will never
be able to play b2 b4 and and keep this
pawn on c6 nicely protected and possibly
essaying
a rook lift so that if this pawn on d5
ever became
weak it have a possible defense
uh a5 well clearly this move rook e1 was
set up with one purpose in mind and that
had to be
to play e3 e4
now let's see what uh
fabiana does not want to allow
e
for e5 into the position then i think
white is just doing spectacularly well
perhaps he has in mind
and
he has indeed liberated his bishop at
last night on d6 looking pretty good i'm
probably
obliged to um
sorry probably obliged to block the
attack of my queen by dropping back and
don't forget there's a little pesh key
hanging right although luckily there's
no in-between move because after bishop
takes d3 you do have to recapture if you
took on e6 you wouldn't have anything to
capture the bishop backwards absolutely
so but now that now the pawn is intake
again yeah it kind of stands out here
like a sore thumb
i think i would prefer well i'm pretty
sure i would prefer white at this moment
yeah this doesn't look like it turned
out so well but maybe we missed
something better well let's try do we
have to play bishop a6
well e3 e4 um
can we try this crazy g4 idea that
that maurice had pointed out in a
previous uh version
doesn't make it well here you haven't
played the movie five
so that just it doesn't make too much
sense to me to play g4 now
so once again let's try captures
oops excuse me let's try captures
captures
anything now maybe something different
maybe something just moving
right now you have no threats maybe we
should just like try to attack d4
it's important to give ourselves that
option of taking on d3 right
e4 yeah
well you can't play around too much this
pawn on c6 is really hampering the
development of the bishop the bishop
steps back then all of white's pieces
look really good
so
where maurice we're going to have to
toss this we're on right back to you
because
where
i'm confused by the move a5 a4 it's a
positional nicety that i really like to
get in but i
am amazed that fabiano can just take it
so easy
i thought the g4 e5 was a necessity and
i'm just looking at e4 and i'm saying
isn't
levant just clearly better
it is a confusing position for me as
well that kingside looks so porous and
all classical theory says open up the
position and you'll be better but take a
look at this line and i've been
analyzing just as you've been befuddled
so have i with the engine and this just
doesn't look that bad for black
in fact doesn't look bad at all the move
e4
can be answered by captures and captures
and now it looks like you've just opened
up the game don't do anything funny
except now we'll play g4 tell your
knight to go somewhere your knight drops
back looks natural
now f5 how anti-positional can you get
with this move weakening the e5 square
making this pawn truly backward
permanently backward and to move bishop
d3 now and you're thinking well if i
could just line up on that pawn i'll be
just sitting pretty now the weird move
rook a5 coming out of nowhere guarding
that square temporarily but looking for
the d5 square for that rook and telling
you that both pieces can't land on c4 it
can't be both the bishop and the knight
and one that lands there the wrong one
landing there will be knocked off the
move bishop c4 is possible here and the
engines actually will take and play rook
d5 that makes sense because now you're
not attacking the pawn anymore the other
move that's interesting is the move
knight to c4 looking to not have that
take happen but now the move rook to d5
comes in and you've got a weak pawn as
well something about this doesn't smell
right you feel weird for black but
according to the engines black is doing
just fine in this position
what can you do yes it's uh it's chess
in 2015. uh what uh
magnus uh well described it
one time as alien chest this is really
weird to bring the rook from a8 and
somehow have it perfectly centralized
after all of those trades
uh it is uh befuddling but there you go
tactically it seems that uh
fabby's position holds quite well let's
do a a around the tour because we
haven't seen uh some of the other games
one of the match-ups i think is very
very key
is the game between
hikaru nakamura where oh did i pass it
i'm afraid i may have passed it
nakamura yeah yeah i've been giving that
one a lot of attention you know nakamura
nand uh nakamura says has a surprisingly
big score against an odds
four to one in their classical games
that's pretty dominant performance by
hicaro against a five-time world
champion sorry oh yeah absolutely and i
mean i'm saying like right now you know
nakamura has often been higher than a
none not at the exact moment but he's
been higher on the top 10 listings but
he started that score even before that
right so he seems to have
um a good time against the nun and we'll
see is he going to continue that trend
here okay they did draw in norway
right uh when they both were having
fabulous results i think it was a
last-round draw nakamura was black
actually um just a big news alert we got
we've got a
capture on g5
by
magnus carlsen so he's grabbed it and
well like i said it would be a 20-minute
thing then you take the bond but okay
we'll come back to that game in a second
but this is a
a crucial match up hikaru nakamura
five-time against five-time world
champion this one-a-thon and none it was
a queen pond opening that quickly became
a catalan
normally what's i always thought those
was really cool i thought this was
modern chess was that the mainline
modern uh variation of the catalan was
the first to give a bishop shack and to
say to white you gained the tempo you
gained the development move bishop d2
but your bishop is actually
worse placed on the d2 square than the
c1 square that was not what
the she did again a very experienced
player bishop b7 bishop g2 all of these
moves
very well known in the catalan
this whole variation has been played on
multiple times
and although the position looks a little
bit dry with this move knight on a5 what
black is dreaming is that he'll be able
to win the two bishops and that this
bishop on g2
will be unopposed on this
beautiful diagonal
h6 bishop e3 and vichy to play if i was
if i were in vichy's shoes i would
probably want to play bishop d5
not to allow this knight capturing the
bishop
first thoughts about this position jen
wouldn't you prefer to be white yeah
absolutely it looks like a
little something for white and i know
that you are used to having this
powerful bishop on g2 yourself oh
absolutely well you love the grunfell
the dragon
anytime you get a fianchetto you feel
happy about your king and this is just a
little bit something but i have to go
back to the first game between magnus
and topalov oh yeah that's where
all the excitement lies certainly
thrilling to see magnus carlsen decide
to take that pawn and yeah unfortunately
he's not going to have a lot of rest
because
immediately smackdown 95 some home
preparation it's quite clear absolutely
and uh maurice uh your thoughts
yeah i just want to correct what you
said yes it ain't the only place there's
excitement in this contest in this round
because the other game with aronia and
karwana has seen that move e5 in this
position e5 has occurred yes please
i know you've got a great memory for
these kind of things i want to figure
you to figure out if you've ever in your
life seeing this pawn formation this
pawn formation looks nuts i cannot
imagine i've ever seen this before in my
entire chest career a4 over here the
pawn on c6 g5 with e5 the only pawn for
holding you up is the pawn on f6 how
often do you play that combo some kings
indians yeah but this ain't the king's
indian at all and look at this position
it's it's nuts and the engine is giving
the most natural move is what e4
you want to start the fight let's do it
and again the response f5 check out that
pawn formation seriously now the best
move according to the engines f3
chillax no problem we're going to keep
this position and then we're gonna crack
your head open
but black can just play rookie eight
stay cool and calm he's gonna lead also
quite soon with the move rook a5 and
the engines are saying it's it's all
good this is cheap stuff this is easy to
calculate no problem
us humans are shaking our heads what
kind of chest are we seeing in 2015 that
they can play this kind of chaotic
random pawn structures and still be just
fine it's amazing to witness the
evolution and revolutionary ideas coming
out in chess uh in this the modern era
you missed the chapter on this pawn
structure uh
yeah modern pawn structures yeah the
four pawn attack by black uh yeah i
missed that four decades of experience
over here and you're right maurice i've
never seen a pawn structure like that in
my life i mean that is really remarkable
one person who has seen it is saviano
carolina
in his board
this morning or and it just happened
we've gotten a couple more moves in fact
we have gotten that structure exactly
wow so let's take a look
so as these players have really been
doing his homework because
uh both players blitzed out oh i'm going
to say the first 15 moves or so then
levon started slowing down and uh a4 a5
a4 came very quickly and where they are
actually even on the clock but
what surprises you about it is it does
seem that white's moves are more a
little bit more obvious so obviously if
fabiano was coming up with this over the
port he would have to have a lot less
time than white because it's much
riskier from the black point of view oh
without question
on g5 right it's just a really smooth
and obvious comparison right true so e3
e4 and this remarkable move f5
i kind of like that what what what black
is trying to do is sucker white into
capturing this pawn so now you're
you've got these double pawns but the
problem is after e4
bishop c4 there's no real dynamic play
in the position and it's clear that
black on the other hand he has a lot of
ways of of
of uh improving his position queen f6
and then also because
a5 at some moment and then which puts
pressure on the pawn allows you perhaps
to take and take on d5 and white center
is all blocked up so that is not a good
situation for white that was why the
computer maurice was mentioning that
maybe f2 f3 to keep that dynamic tension
and then just this calm little move rook
e8 the whole position's
absurd i mean it's crazy really just uh
i absolutely have beautiful
ideas here by black to make what looks
into
an awful position um and really make the
pieces harmonized yes because it's very
surprising you know you see that bishop
on c8
they aren't doing anything and
then suddenly it pops out and it takes
over the game sometime in the work off
and draining the fray on a5 it's it's
really pretty cool so what we're seeing
right now are tactics that are favorable
for fabiano and i'm sure levon is just
kind of like stunned
uh because so many uh
principles that we take for granted uh
are being violated mauricio maurice with
another game
talk about violating principles i mean
just forget about me giving my students
any lessons from now on because here
comes another one don't bring your queen
out too soon
keep it back right you want to move it a
couple of times in the opening not a
good idea well not apparently if you're
like 27 90
screw those ideas like whatever because
queen a4 check in this position between
the game wesley seoul and maxim vashila
grav knight to c6 and now knight g5
moving a piece twice in the opening
naturally castles is a move here queen
c4 even if you're going to violate a
principle attacking this this pawn on c5
and the knight if you're going to play a
move queen c4 has been tried knight g5
you got to go way back uh the 90s where
this move was not that special laputian
played it a couple of times 1-1 lost one
and otherwise not much seen so vasila
graph took some time played e6 since his
knight was under attack from this bishop
in this night and now knight ge4
talking to this pawn on c5 saying you
know maybe i can win you and we're
tacking on the dark squares as well
knight b6 attacking the queen and now
you think the queen would you know i
bluffed enough let me go home
no i'm going to stick my nose in there
now
this kind of move i see yasser you're
going nuts on this one like
what what are you doing in there like
you really think you're going to steal a
pawn like that right from the opening
and here black can simply and i'm
checking to see if he's moved yet he
hasn't moved yet black can simply castle
right you want your pawn take it you
made three night moves knight f3 knight
g5 94. you made two queen moves already
you're gonna have to make another move
with the queen or the knight so you're
wasting six moves with two pieces just
to steal a pawn now granted white
doesn't have any weaknesses but boy he's
behind in development big time so for
example let's take a look at one line
queen takes on c5 knight to d4 the old
okie doke knight c2 check is in the
position if you get out of there by
castling now black says okay my turn f5
find a place for this knight well you've
already covered it with that one that oh
boy now you got to go in again knight c2
move the rook rook b1 and now bishop d4
and uh defend that night and now you're
crying because you're can't and this
knight is going down this night covers
these two squares from the queen to be
able to defend this knight so that line
is just simply bad for for white well
let's go back you could have taken with
the queen you could also take with the
knight but still knight d4 is coming in
and after the queen dealing with this
threat drops back to d3 to guard the c2
square now queen to e7 now he's starting
to punch hit somebody knight back to b3
trying to trade this guy off i dare you
take that one my pawn shows up on that
square bishop is threatening f5 or even
to e6 to go into c4 and it's like what
did wesley do this is not what he wanted
so i'm wondering right now we still have
this position on the board after
queen 94 queen to b5 this is the
position we have on the board and i'm
expecting and it did not happen he did
not castle just as i was talking he
played the move c4 saving his pawn a
good move for black as well by the way
maxine vashila grav getting her from the
board this is also a good move and
wesley so you got to wonder
what was his preparation about when
black has so many options to get a good
position after you're moving piece after
piece after piece and you can't even
prove anything right now i mean if you
don't prove anything you're just worse
and the engines are saying
yeah he's just actually kind of worse
already
not really a great choice by
the young
filipino who's now representing the
united states so
we've got to see what he's got by going
into this line yes i know you didn't
play the english like this no i didn't
normally i like to be a head in
development not behind and wasting that
many moves again one two three moves
with the knight one two the queen five
moves in the opening
uh
just for two pieces and the move c5 c4
is a very human move you want to hold
your material right i like castles too
because it was clear black was getting
great dynamic tactical play but this
move c4 just basically asked why well
haven't you just spent a lot of time and
if
black is able to execute castles and e5
and
who knows starting to harass white's
queen with a6 maybe as maurice pointed
out f7 f5
white is just simply very very very much
worse the only way i was the only way i
was i could make the or try to make
a heads or tails of wesley's play was
with the move b3 hoping just hoping that
i would be able to play bishop a3 and
knight d6 check of course i'm not going
to be able to get away with that uh
borrowing a page from maurice you could
castle but here's actually
maybe a difference that
for is actually pretty reasonable white
now gets to play the move queen b1
instead of getting his queen kicked out
all the way around of course knight
takes c4 i think black is just fine
don't get me wrong
but at least no crying yeah yeah exactly
there was going to be some crying uh
earlier
but we're gonna take a quick break we'll
be right back uh this round is gonna be
a hot one it's exciting
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't want to
skip st louis is the stop but non-stop
find so much fun for your family
infinity plus a ton there's museums full
of art and super fun slides upside down
concrete's twisty turny rides houses
full of magic some with butterflies
infinity plus a ton
healthcare in america is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation
ascension is made up of physicians and
other caregivers called to deliver
compassionate personalized care for all
as one of the largest providers of care
in the country our patients benefit from
collaboration between hospitals medical
practices and health care innovators
nationwide ascension's faith-based
heritage means we have a moral
obligation to serve everyone especially
those who are struggling last year we
provided almost 2 billion in care for
people living in poverty and for
programs to help them whether it's in a
hospital a neighborhood clinic a senior
living facility or at home ascension's
care providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
ascension
hello and welcome back to the 2015 sink
field cup look at that crowd it's a
weekend in saint louis packed house i
think you saw that commercial about the
awesome sights of st louis and of course
visiting the central west end right now
particularly beautiful perfect weather
and you get to see all of these fabulous
players in the flash if you're lucky to
get an autograph there were hundreds of
players yesterday
who um came to get autographs over 300
and counting including lots of
youngsters now we've got this a critical
match up between the world champion
magnus carlson and topolov to see if uh
magnus can get some revenge for the ugly
ending of norway chess 2015 where he
actually lost on time from a winning
position that's right and um hammer
actually who was our wild card in the
first leg of the sink field cup
of the grandchildren oh sorry of the
grand chester yes he said that if
atopalov um spent more than a couple
minutes
after nine bishop e2
he was um
pretty excited about his uh magnus's
chances because it meant that um topalov
had forgotten
his home preparation for clinton or
maybe not played as much attention to
exactly maybe he wasn't looking at
bishop two as much as some of those
other crazy variations that we were
looking at right okay but after bishop
e2 in another game right
yeah
and carlson and bishop e2 in wesley so's
game right now
we had started uh when we got this
position a little while ago jen we were
looking at rook g8 immediately
uh attacking this knight and trying to
coax f4 oh the names are temporarily
wrong in this board but that's fine oh
yeah not sure why that is the second uh
you got it right now yeah okay perfect
okay so i just have to refresh 95 bishop
e2 let's just take our pawn back we take
c4 so that we're setting up this move
rookie 8 but more important rook g8
pardon me but more importantly we're
giving our knight a square so that in
case of the hyper aggressive f2 f4 i can
just
as black jump into the d3 square gaining
a tempo and forcing this trade now it's
true the spawn on d3
is probably going to be lost in fact it
might just get picked up right away
after for example queen b3 but it takes
time
for
and this is the type of position that a
lot of sicilian players would embrace
this half open g file getting your
bishop on the long diagonal bishop b7
and i like the compensation here for
vessel and he loves the two bishops
might i say maurice your thoughts
well i'm going to patent myself on the
back and say that that's the moves i
thought that magnus was going to play it
is very much in accordance with his
style to play that idea of just bringing
the bishop back to e2 and knight f3 he's
not going to play f4 i think he's going
to play knight f3 and that one
challenging the knight on the e5 square
but i would be remiss if i didn't let
everyone know that it has indeed
happened
carwana played the move f5 huge paw
information you just take a picture of
it now you know you're not going to see
this again or maybe we'll start seeing
it all the time this kind of crazy pawn
formation here with four black pawns
you know the four pawn attack with the
g-pawn involved crazy chess has broken
out here and i think aronian he smelled
a rat when he played e4 he seemed very
confident then he came back to the board
and i think he realized that f5
was in the position
and karana playing that kind of super
aggressive chess that is his wounds and
also now we've seen moves
on the board topolof did capture on c4
so black playing hyper aggressively in
those two games but i'd like to point
out yet another game that seemed strange
this move we saw the queen the knight
moved three times the queen moved twice
and now wesley so has brought his knight
to c3 and now to a4 because we all know
that knights belong on the side of the
board and moving the same piece twice
another piece twice again that's seven
moves for three pieces while all these
guys are wondering when they'll ever
move black again here can simply castle
sacrifice the c pawn yeah i'll lose it
maybe we could have lost it on c5 now it
looks like he is going to lose it on c4
but it's just fine for him just castles
here and you can go after this as much
as you want with this capture here the
engines are still
loving black in this position multiple
moves e5 being one of them getting ready
to put the bishop on e6 the knight on d4
a rook on the c file tremendous play in
that line and already it's saying down
upon is black yes but black is way ahead
according to the computer's evaluation
i don't know what wesley's doing quite
honestly these kind of moves i'd like
smack my student's hand and say take
that move back we're not analyzing that
at all but here we have a player
2770 2780 playing chess like this
he he might suffer in the long run for
making these types of exotic moves
exotic moves that's the theme of the
round indeed wow uh but i i'm
quite stunned by uh wesley's approach to
this game because it's very clear that
should he play knight takes b6
and let's just for example i don't know
put a move like queen takes b6 even
you you've invested so much energy into
winning the pawn you better just take a
queen take c4 e5 it's clear that white
white is going to be under a great deal
of pressure knight's coming to d4 very
easy for
flowing uh for black bishop e6 rook t a
rook c8 knight d4
great calm and in the meanwhile as uh
maurice pointed out you got a rook on a1
and you're having you've got four pieces
that are
on the first round you attack uh
grabbing a pawn so
so harshly well
normally speaking you know i don't give
my phone it's such a great you know
compensation but this isn't even
compensation this is simply good
for black so we better
hope wesley's fans better hope that he
has
uh
not underestimated his opponent
in this particular game just going to go
to the game of anish giri by the way in
norway
there were three players that went
through that whole field undefeated and
one of them was anishgiri
hikaru nakamura and vishy anand
and
in their game between anishigiri and
alexander grishop this is again
one of those catalan positions where
black has won a pawn he's got this pawn
on c4 but white has these beautiful well
the centric pandua
and he's looking to uh isolate this
knight on the rim with the move knight
e5 so what happened was
uh
he went back knight f6 h3 and what anish
is really really hoping you'll never see
sasha do this which is trade and just
allow uh white rook on a1 to play a huge
role in the game so for the moment
black's a pawn up but he has some issues
that he has to solve
yeah that's right and sasha of course
being a nickname for alexander yes
uh russian uh nickname okay uh and again
i just want to go back to our
i think feature table
um
vessel and top former world champion
vessel and topalov
against
yeah against reigning world champion
magnus carlson
and
the players have really slowed down i
don't know exactly the times if those
are accurate or not one it looks like
119 for magnus and 136 for topalov and
yeah remember there's no increment in
this first time kendra and yes exactly
which is funny because you know i talked
to some of the players about that and i
to me it seems that because the game
time has an average longer length that
would benefit the players who uh like to
spend more time but they these guys
think it's the opposite because just by
virtue of not having an increment it
gives you that incentive to move a
little bit or just like it gives the
possibility that you'll end up having
five moves to make with like just just
like 30 seconds and then it could just
become a complete disaster exactly
whereas normally even though it's a
shorter average monthly gain there's
kind of that built-in security blanket
right and obviously for these guys at
their incredible level and they've also
all had so much experience in rapids
having 30 seconds for a move especially
for somebody like gruishik
yeah well he can sneak up on you
i think maurice was saying that instead
of the hyper aggressive f2 f4 that he is
expecting
again magnus to try to tap down
the dynamics of the position simply drop
back with the knight quite frankly we do
not want to allow ourselves this capture
i was thinking that
in any case obviously vessel has showed
his
desire if you will to sacrifice upon
bishop d3 you could take take
and essentially what black is hoping is
that when he gets his bishop on this b7
square that he'll exert enough
pressure down this long diagonal that
his compensation will be outstanding we
can try a quick e5
well that i think would actually play
into uh topolof's hands in a sense the
move e5 does open up the diagonal so
let's imagine we take it let's imagine
we recapture what what else
queen d5 may be
premature so let me try bishop h6 so
what i was
this idea of playing queen b3
um double attacking um you can actually
just interpose with the piece on d5
and again if i take on f7 with the same
idea i it doesn't quite work because you
can just play bishop d5 or queen d5 so
instead of that was the that was what uh
what vessel is hoping is that he'll get
these threats on the long diagonal so
okay that's no good so just a little
illusion there that it's good for you
but you can play queen to a4 check as
you were pointing out and that might be
annoying because then the knight's got
to drop back and i'm in a pin and now we
can consider playing a queen to b3 and
getting or knight f7 exactly right right
and then suddenly it's uh
the the tightest shift but here
let's try in this position
a move like bishop h6 in order just to
give the f 8 square open up the f 8
square for the king
and i like this for black i think that
black is ready
because again just look at all the
pieces
we have three here just let's just look
at the most direct idea here
okay queen f3 let's see what we can do
to
have some fun
okay i can't well
can i allow knight c6 that's my question
it also looks like we're throwing queen
essex and knight c6 perhaps
queen c6 and sorry well
what move were you thinking
i'm thinking of uh losing my rook
ah okay take my rooks yeah but that
sounds like a good book title yeah but
then on the other hand rooks are nice
people so okay i'll play bishop e6 just
keeping the defense
for me opening up the protection of the
rook now you've got a choice you can go
after this pawn you can go after this
pawn or you can develop
yeah um so and
you just have a nice little escape for
if i played at c6 right well my whole
dream i don't know if it's going to work
it may just absolutely not work but my
dream is to play rook g8 and the bishop
d5
and again at the moment i'm still not
upon down and you've got some
development to solve now again i've got
a lot of targets in the position but
this is the way
uh vessel implants
if you can take a pawn but then all of
my active pieces are
are becoming uh more defensive so all
your activities well my knight and my
queen this is my only active thesis
what do you got for us
well in that spectacular pawn formation
it just gets richer and richer the game
between aronian and caruana and after
the move f5
he looked at it did aronian and say okay
capture capture
wait a minute what's working here if he
takes on e5 takes on e4 we look to this
line e takes d6 e takes d3 one thing we
didn't look at queen and rook are under
attack right now maybe white could throw
an e takes on d takes on c7 and say hey
maybe i get a tempo on this and then i
steal the pawn
well wake up and smell the coffee
because queen to f6 now hits this pawn
on f2 as well as maintains the fork in
the position you definitely cannot
capture here because that's going to be
all she wrote after queen takes f2 check
king h1 and thanks for the mate that you
just handed me so that would be over so
after looking at those complications he
saw the move f5 he said let me just play
the move f3 and keep everything solid
and see what happens next the move we're
expecting
is rook to e8 at least the move that the
engines are saying is best is rook to ea
here keeping all the tension alive there
are all kinds of tricks if you take on
f5 then e takes on d4 hitting the queen
queen f2 and now bishop takes f5 and
black's pieces have sprung to life the
king doesn't look as bad as you would
hope rook takes queen takes and queen
takes are all natural material balancing
moves but after queen to e6
black just looks fine as rook's going to
come over to e8 he dominates the main
lines of play
white doesn't have any attack going
anywhere
black just looks fine and caruana
playing very well it doesn't seem as
though black has such a big advantage
that aronia will think well now i'm much
worse i'm suffering so i think you see
there lavonne is very calm his moves are
a bit easier to play and it's up to
karana to keep finding those funky moves
that he's he's been playing so far but i
will point out very importantly we did
see the win of the pawn happen in the
other game let's get to this position
remember we talked about wesley soul
moving those pieces many times well
three times with this knight to get to
e4 and now after castles by vacilla grav
three times with that knight to capture
on b6 and now the third move by the
white queen so three moves by one night
three moves by the other three by the
queen i think that adds up to nine moves
with just three pieces we're only on
move 13 guys move 13 of the game white
is up a pawn
but black with what you called yes not
just compensation just a fine position a
move like e5 screams to be played bishop
d7 with a rook coming with threats are
in the position already black has to be
careful white has to be careful about c2
e2 might hang when the knight lands on
d4 i mean just tremendous tremendous
play for the black pieces but wesley so
is there i've got the pawn now prove it
thank you maurice well indeed that's a
great challenge going on in that game
but i do like mvl's position going back
to our game of the round magnus carlson
we have seen
the move d5 take c4 and by the way we've
been kind of
back and forth between knight g5 and f3
by the world champion or
f2 f4 there's actually even a third move
to be considered and that i think
is the move knight a3 hoping to pick up
the pawn in by this fashion knight takes
e4
still there's something about the
position that doesn't feel
right for me uh
uh magnus's position and it's the vision
of seeing all of these queen side pieces
on their original squares and most
specifically this bishop on c1
when
white forces that knight to get to d3
and that pawn to get to d3 it's very
hard to activate this bishop on c1 so
i'm sure magnus is looking for
alternative
uh
moves that get his queen side
development if you play knight a3 after
knight d3 we can also analyze queen a4
check and queen c4 that's exactly that
knight one queen f7 jack
yeah or something like that so knight a3
and lastly there's even something to be
said for b3 uh again i'm i'm thinking if
i'm white i want to get my pieces out i
just don't want them sitting on the
front row doing anything and um again
maybe knight f3 is the best move but
yeah after knight f3 knight d3 there's
i this this position
just doesn't have an appeal to me if i'm
so magnus picking a smart time to really
take his time because this is a critical
decision which will cover the rest of
the game without question
let's talk about the confession booth
that we have here which we also had in
norway
so if the players during the game have
something to get off their chests they
want to talk about the game what's going
on it's really exciting for the viewers
so all these players have the option to
use the confession booth and grandmaster
alejandro ramirez is going to test it
out for us all right
well we are here at the floor of the
playing hall the players are right over
there and a cool new feature of the 2015
sink field cup is as in norway the
players have the option of using a
confessional booth for them to just say
what they're thinking to say out loud
their thoughts and maybe even collect
themselves a little bit when we can show
you everything they say so let's check
it out let's come
so this area is soundproof and the
players can come here and say their
thoughts
i can pretend to be topalov and be like
oh you know g5 i was just bluffing or
something and hopefully the players use
it often so we know what they're
thinking
and well that's the confessional booth
back to you jen and yasser wow i hope
nobody makes me go on the confession
i might be in it for way too long i've
been hogging it off i was about to say
that you know
um sometimes you know you make a move
and you're proud of the movie mate and
then you get up from the board and go oh
gosh that's a
terrible move it's a blunder i go into
the confession move just to scream
like ah
i did it wrong oh it is soundproof but
if you scream loud enough somebody might
try to help you well if you scream in
space and there's nobody there to hear
you do you still make a sound
well we look forward to hearing from
some players in the confession booth and
we're actually going to take a little
break here at the 2015 sink field cup
our second lid of the grand chest store
but we've had fun and it's only the
first hour and a half
of what 60 hours of excitement in this
year's field cup so stay tuned we'll be
right back
so
better
uh
so
no
that's
so
okay
hello and welcome back to the 2015
sinfield cup our very exciting first
round where we've got a crazy battle on
our hands in the crosstain topalov game
where
paulova sacrificed a pawn right out of
the gate and magnus did play your move
knight to a3
well what do grandmasters do on their
break why
they analyze the chess games of course
and maurice and i are mesmerized by what
is going on in this game of the world
champions
and we've been looking at this position
after knight eight three
and after serious contemplation the
engines don't like that move well that
hit in the front row though with the
aqua glasses like that so i'm saying
i i would definitely take his word over
the computer oh yeah well we've seen
this move rook g8 and that's put uh
magnus into the tank
and the engines now
have
are believed that white has absolutely
got to play the move
d2d4 which doesn't
fit in the link of bishop e2 and knight
a3 knight a3 obviously had the intention
of simply snapping that pawn and now
you're giving black
the opportunity
to capture
any day that you get to capture on
passant is a day worth living is that
right that's in that's a famous jessica
right out of philadelphia
where does that one come from but anyway
magnus is not going to have that pawn in
hand that he may have thought he was
going to have and instead it's just
become a kind of a messy open sicilian
looking game where black's king is going
to be stuck in the center for a long
while but white is facing some king side
threats that he's going to have to take
very seriously and those two facts are
of course related right
absolutely and maurice has some news on
another game that we've been focused on
this round between wesley solar wild
card and
the always exciting player maxine bashir
well you mentioned yasser a king being
stuck in the middle of the board well
take a look at this king what wesley so
has gone in there grabbed this pong went
in the cookie jar grabbed the pawns yeah
i got it and now he's looking at the
board and going
i don't think i want it anymore because
right now
it is maximum vascular with the move e5
that's saying what pawn did you take
buddy here comes my bishop to e6 my
knight's going to land on d4 let's just
take a look at a variation if your king
leaves the center right now first of all
i'm attacking this pawn
you can't even defend it that's just
freebie if i want it back but if you
drop back to c2 i'm not taking it knight
d4 attacking your e2 pawn and the pawn
on a2 still oh your queen has to move
hey wait a minute did you smell this one
coming bishop to b3 now
winning in exchange of course queen
moving over here to to e1 uh just simply
runs into uh he could actually just take
on a2 with the threat of knight c2
knight b3 trapping everything
just just over
this position here with the queen taking
on c4 moving this night three times
remember we said
we were wondering
what do i tell my students don't move
the same piece over and over again in
the opening don't bring your queen out
without a good reason move it a couple
of times don't go upon grabbing if
you're about down in development i was
worried that i couldn't say those words
anymore well guess what they hold true
still at least in this position and
white is in deep trouble in this
position the engine is already saying
black after the move e5 is sitting
pretty you just took a pawn and the move
e5 lands and engines are like no no this
is horrible for white so wesley in a
whole bunch of hurt now there's another
position that i'm very concerned about
for fabiano there's a principle
there's a principle let's go back to
this moment there's a principle in chess
called maintaining the tension
maintaining the attention gregory
cardano of grand master gregory cardano
of one of the great teachers uh one of
the great coaches in america today if
not the world when he was training me to
get the grandmaster title he noticed
often that i captured when i shouldn't i
captured too soon and he would say dude
you got to maintain the tension don't
blink first maintain the tension so in
this kind of position well even if we go
back a couple of moves after the move e5
lavon said well i won't capture i'll
even ratchet up the tension move f5 well
i'm not trading either i'm bringing up
even more well guess what i'm not either
f3 we're maintaining the tension as much
as possible and the engines agreed with
all these moves and now they move rook
to e8 was maintain the tension some more
instead the move d takes e4 came while
on the break i was sitting down on my
laptop and when i looked up and saw that
move i said whoa
gregory would be saying something's
wrong with that and the engines agree
that this move is somewhat scary after f
takes e4 you know it's a tricky move
because the pawn can go down the board
you have to calculate carefully now
they're interesting it's still okay if
you take on d4 here but you get the
feeling like white got something like
black did something weird to the
position and actually now as you give it
to the engines to think a little bit
more now they're saying it's not okay
after the move e5
that human intuition that basic
principle we are guided by principles
not necessarily just by calculation but
mainly by principles and this one's
saying this is good for white this is
looking kind of good
the move instead of that
after fe4 instead of e takes d4 rook to
a5 and here the engines also really like
white because now you can take on f5 and
you've got to be super careful
this position after bishop takes on f5
now d takes e5 and white's just sitting
pretty the position's falling apart for
black and also the move
knight takes on f5 and white could now
play this move bishop to c4 check
driving him in the corner and then d5
with threats to the e pawn 94 coming
black again in big trouble so maintain
that tension that's the lesson for this
position and now it is up to
to aronian after rook a5 to find the
right sequence the pressure is on he's
deep in thought he knows about
maintaining attention trust me and he's
he saw him just wiggle a little bit
there feeling pretty confident about his
chances but he's got to find the right
move still in this very crazy position
thank you maurice and uh in their
personal head-head match-up they played
lots of times but they both had had the
full measure of one another five
victories for uh levothyrone four for
fabiano so they both know uh
how to defeat one another and at the
moment it looks very good
for lavon
bringing
us right back to that game of wesley so
and mvl
recognizing all of those things that you
had said maurice and most particularly
that bishop that nasty bishop b3 line
wesley dropped back with his queen
voluntarily and it looks like what he
wants to do is tuck his queen away after
a move like knight d4 to get his queen
back on the first
uh
rank and he's sitting there saying okay
uh i've dropped the pawn but check this
out that same variation that you
mentioned maurice bishop e6
and if you play for example a developing
move or trying to develop with move like
d3 bishop b3
taking advantage of this pin on the a
file and white's going to have to cough
up in exchange so that's clearly not
what wesley has in mind after knight d4
queen c queen c2 pardon knight d4 i
think what wesley has in mind is putting
his queen on the square b1 so that he
can keep an eye on this rook on a1 this
is not an attractive way
of playing the game right so we could
get that perfect formation no that
sometimes comes up in fishing random
yeah this is this is looking a little
bit like official random
position and i just
i don't like the way that this is uh
has
developed for wesley for example
bishop f5 a very natural developing move
and if we play a move for example like
d3 just imagine a line like this rook c8
in order to play knight c2 and
after a move like knight oh it doesn't
work i wanted to say there's even a
queen trap which there is but of course
you would have recaptured on e2 with the
queen let me just go back to this
position for a moment and start with the
move bishop takes
bishop takes naturally rook c8 and it's
not possible to prevent
the knight from coming to c2
maybe white can scramble for
compensation with the move like castles
but even if he wanted to black could
capture this pawn never mind he could
also pick up the exchange so i do not
like this
well horrible yeah but i just
it's not an attractive way
for wesley to play this game so
definitely the opening edge has gone to
mvl and as we start our middle game i
like black's position after bishop f5
yes
why do we have to play d3
well i just didn't know what else to do
yeah
yeah i know i mean you know
well maybe e3 here pardon me i apologize
e3 is still a move and
let me see can i
am just a little bit worried that my
king might become uh the focus of
attention but it looks okay looks okay
i'll have to probably step back with the
knight so i got ideas like knight c5
right kind of holding in on that d3
square as well precisely but okay i mean
in for a penny in for a pound p4
again it looks like there's great
compensation to be had here for black
and wesley is going to have to solve a
lot of problems over the next five to
ten moves before it can breathe a little
easier uh 1 16 for mbl
uh 123 in terms of type 109 now in terms
of time and even yeah and even in that
variation it looks dangerous because you
know the d2 pawn is hanging in the end
yeah so
well let me just get up to date uh with
the players uh queen c2 and we're
going to be able to play yeah
um
and marisa smiling about a different
game we can can head over to uh
nakamura and anand
nakamura had a slight pool earlier
and we know he's got a great score
against fishy
what's going on now maurice
well i was looking at this position i
was thinking oh slight edge for white
but you know it's a little bit of a
snoozefest so we can ignore that game uh
unless something dramatic happen well
something dramatic has occurred in this
game and you guys can guess the move
before i even say it you can guess the
move
bishop back to d2 after 95 knight b6
bishop to f4 i'm thinking
what are you trying for
equal draw maybe knight going back to d5
what's the point of that now knight e5
now there's some very solid ways for
black to play this position super solid
ways just one beginning with knight
takes on f4 and bishop takes g2 the
engines love that for black black's just
fine no problems at all but vichy said
you know what
all the sex appeal is happening on the
other two boards nobody's paying
attention to me i think i just need to
play the same move and now g5 is on the
board we like seeing moves like this but
in this position it might come with a
little bit of a caveat because the guy
can just drop back with bishop to d2 and
we're back in this position but now
you've got this pawn sticking out on the
g5 square
this move knight to b6 might still have
been playable but not with the knight
now on e5 that's a big difference in the
position knight takes on c6 is now
possible anything captures here we keep
taking on c6 b takes and now bishop to
a5 and the whole position is way
different white is the one with all the
pressure looks like white is in fact way
better maybe close to winning in this
line so what's up with this move g5 on
move 21 it's been the move of the round
so far three players now with the black
pieces dropping this move on the board
but you could see nakamura there he has
the intense eyes of a hawk thinking
there's something wrong with that i've
got to prove it
well all he has to do in fact is just
drop back to d2
but you know he smells something fishy
and it ain't fishy i imagine in this
position but that move g5 looks quite
wrong
it seems to be the round for g7 g5 no
question about that getting that in
three games this early in the round we
did not see that move a d to d4
uh
no and then we saw knight take c knight
takes c4
whoa what is knight take c4 yeah
just a second help me clear the cobwebs
here jen
if we capture the night
we're a piece up
simultaneously we've got an attack here
there's some knight f7 tricks that i
don't quite yeah it must be something
like that or
uh
i'm in a little bit of a shock here
because the world champion seems to have
sacrificed a piece with his last vote
knight takes c4
maybe d4
this looks really too weird for words
what is going on
knight just drops back
i don't quite see it myself so what
about your night takes f7 drive
i don't believe it
king takes f7
bishop takes c4 at the moment it's only
a pawn or what does the body count seven
one two three four
five two pawns
nah that came out we're missing
something man let's let's take a so
knight c4 okay we're gonna go back just
for a moment so this is the position on
the board magnus carlson ignored the
threat to his g5 night which was just
placed under attack and instead he said
i'm clipping upon
knight takes e4 that's right so
now first of all there is rook takes g5
of course but i rejected that because i
thought well let's punish
white uh f2 f4 and then after takes on
c4 you have it takes g5 hitting another
piece so you can create that nice you
end up a headed material right correct
so the key variation is what to do after
knight takes c4 correct knight takes c4
is our main line and now we just kind of
like
stumbled and stopped
we go what
it what does the world champion have in
mind
clearly
this
plays right into black's hands he's just
a piece
nothing there
so we've got to do we're looking at like
knight takes f7 or
d4 right f4 or d4
you look at d4 and then after knight b6
we stopped but what about e5 maybe or
taking on c5
yeah taking on c5 okay we'll fall
forward takes takes
now again there's a pawn that could be
had by trading queens but then we traded
queens and we're not happy about that
queen b3 would seem
legit okay we're
we're swimming here and
it is not the
maybe the knight takes f7 line well
grandmaster more east ashley your
thoughts on uh
this amazing decision by uh c4 by magna
carlos by magnus carlson
my thoughts i i i'm like
what just happened is my thoughts that's
crazy the move knight takes on c4 in
this position and the engines however
are saying that okay white might have
some minimal compensation here after
knight takes c4 that just is a piece in
hand you don't want to take back here
because your knight is hanging so the
move is d4 being given by the engines as
you guys pointed out and now black and
simply now that this knight is not on
take but his is it's time to just drop
it back a5 or b6 both good squares and
now white has to prove something white
has multiple moves all of them are crazy
but might lead back to some comp takes
on c5 is a natural move here black can
ignore with e5 that's a good move black
can also take and ask him about this
position queen takes king takes knight
f7 being given as the best king to e8
and knight e5
you look at this but you say tobolov is
thinking you want to play this against
me you're going to be in trouble you
don't want to play like this he's a
piece down yes he got back some pawns
for it two pawns but it's not going to
be enough as these bishops are going to
go nuts and the extra piece will count
in a few moves so just looking at the
line it seems as though after knight
takes on c4 topalov is still thinking no
he did actually capture on c4 and d4 has
occurred so we're going down this line i
can't imagine after the move knight a5
when we're guarding the square on b3 so
no queen b3 tricks it looks as though
it's not that special for white and
white is going to go down in this
position unless he comes up with
something sharper maybe a move like e5
could be possible but is ending up in
the same kind of end games after this
capture
not impressive after queen d1 and the
computers are like i don't know what
white thinks he has but it looks like he
doesn't have anything special in the
short term or even the long term nothing
to point at that says that the world
champion should have played like this so
we're gonna have to see what magnus
carlsen has cooked up in this position
what he's thinking about as to why he
would sack a piece for a very little
reason
wow wow either it's inspired or simply
it i mean that's what it comes down to
right i mean and we'll find the results
so in the confessional so the first time
at least save this game
be very careful now
i think we missed what he he said
we did get that he has to be very
careful now you know it's not that
surprising to see whether
he
so he knows he's in trouble and he's
trying to find a way to save the game
that was his confession and i'm not that
surprised to uh see wesley be the first
one to utilize the confessional in the
press conference yesterday he mentioned
how much he loved the idea he wants
chess to be more popular
and obviously he likes the idea of
motivating
the viewers to keep tuning in
well when i think of a confessional i
think of absolution so was he asking for
absolution for
his poor play or something well we'll
see but um
okay we've got actually a special guest
here we've got jeffrey hart with the
city of st louis and he's also a board
member of the st louis chess club he's
with grandmaster maurice ashley to talk
about the impact events like this are
having on the city
yes we are with jane
jeff excuse me rainford jeff uh we met a
while back you introduced me to
demetrius johnson who was a wonderful
guy and and has been doing quite a lot
for chess in the city tell us how you
met demetrius and why you thought that
was important for for him to be doing
what he's doing well demetrius is a
former pro football player or uh one of
the you know one of the best players
ever to go to the university of missouri
and after he left football he's really
been doing a lot with kids particularly
inner city kids and inner-city
african-american young men
and i uh you know i introduced demetrius
to some of the people here at the center
and i said you know chess could be a
really important part of what you're
doing for these kids to give them
alternatives to violence and drugs and
some of the other things that are
happening and at first i remember when
we were at lunch uh not far from here
and he like looked at me like i had
three heads or something but then he met
you and met other folks and uh he became
a true believer and recently he had a
tournament with uh with uh inner city uh
african and high school football players
they played chess against each other as
a team and the intensity you know it was
not as intense as what we're seeing here
today but for their level it was the
same amount of intensity and really i
think the coolest thing about the whole
thing is you and demetrius and other
people are making it cool to be smart
and there are lots of places lots of
neighborhoods in st louis and across the
country where it's not cool to be smart
so i think it's one of the mo the most
fundamental and the greatest
contributions to you know st louis is
now you know probably the chess capital
of america and that's probably one of
the greatest contributions to our city
is getting more people involved more
kids involved in chess i know that you
were working with the mayor slay and now
you have your own consulting firm
why is it that uh chess is booming here
like in such a great way that we see the
city supporting it we see the mayor
supporting it yourself demetrius johnson
saint louis would you have thought this
as someone who who's from the city that
this would be happening here in such a
great way well yes and no first of all
there's a lot of st louis both in the
past and right now there's been we have
a history there's a lot of brain power
here we have washington university near
here one of the great universities we
have bjc one of the great medical
complexes one of the great symphonies
one of the great art museums so we have
a history of doing this but if we're
going to be honest with each other uh it
would not have happened without rex and
jeannie singfield i mean they have been
the you know the people who who have
made the commitment themselves they're
the ones who got the rest of us excited
i'm sure the first time rex and jeannie
told the mayor and me hey we want to
make st louis the chess capital of the
world i probably looked at them like
they had three heads but you know what
they were right i mean it really has
been a phenomenal thing and again it
clearly is good for st louis's brand i
mean you know when you're talking about
bringing the smartest men and women in
the world to st louis you know now st
louis univer
uh webster university now has a really
good team um and it brings great repute
to our city
lindenwood is is building a great team
you know and it's the kind of thing that
you want your city to be known as and
again you know i know how to play chess
but i i'm not a particularly good chess
player but i'm going to ask you that
question
but i appreciate you feel like being in
a place like this with all this brain
power and all this great chess going on
so i was watching you all talk about the
the game going on with magnus and you're
scratching your heads and i i thought
maybe you were speaking another language
you know i just got back from paris
where you know i only speak a little bit
of french and that's the way that i felt
but you know in my life i have to think
strategically so i i get the general
concept of it um but more importantly
it's such a great game i'm a member of
the club even though i'm i'm not an avid
player because i really do i know enough
about chess to know that it that the
more of our kids who are doing it the
better it is for them and the more st
louis has thought of uh
you know in in the context of chess the
better it's going to be for our city
well jeff we appreciate that uh that
kind of support and we look forward to
more of that support in years to come
and you know we often look at rex like
he has three heads that's that's normal
for him well let me just say this though
here's the other thing about uh what you
guys are doing the three of you do you
know it's the same thing if somebody
said oh they're gonna do a live
broadcast of chess i'd be like how can
they possibly make that interesting and
the three of you i'm pretty sure could
could make anything interesting you guys
do a great job and i think that's
important i you know uh when i was a kid
major league baseball had started
turning its back on younger fans and
then they finally discovered one day
that you know major league baseball
wasn't as popular and they went back and
they were mindful about what they did
they started the games earlier so more
kids can go what you guys are doing with
the broadcasting of these events and the
way that you do it and make it
interesting into a broader audience is
really good for the game of chess and
especially for the game of chess in
america and the three of you along with
rex and genie and other folks may be the
ones that you know hopefully a
generation of generation from that from
now american chess players are really
thought of the same way that i think
other people think of russian chess
players and the like so you guys are
doing a great job well we appreciate
that very much and we'll keep doing our
part all right thanks so much thanks for
having me jeff rainford with rayford and
associates supporting chess here in st
louis it takes a team and he's part of
it and so are we and proud to be so guys
back to you thank you jeff thank you
maurice wow and things are really
heating up but just across all the
boards by the way it's just it's just
it's just fantastic i'm looking at the
game of hikaru nakamura
versus five-time world champion vishy
anand and as we know they both had great
uh event in norway so this is a key
match-up as they get this tournament
underway after the move
g5
uh we actually thought that vishy might
be in a little bit of trouble bishop
d2 but vishy shows that he's still got
everything under control he's just
tossed out this move b7 b6
encouraging hikaru to grab the two
bishops knight takes c6 and you think
from a long-term perspective it's going
to be nice for white
but
thanks to this pawn being on the a2
square the v3 square is weak and vishy
has his own ideas if he could plant his
knight on d4 which
simultaneously attacks this pawn on e2
he'll also
be able to go knight d4 to b3 with a
nice little fork against rook and bishop
and he will have solved his problems
well especially considering the fact
that we would probably ideally want to
put our effort on c1 but that would
further come into fire of your knight
and b3 exactly so it it you know at
first blush it really did look very very
good for vichy
uh but you mean
for white
and then suddenly after this move b7 b6
which
you know forces this
what looks like this force before
actually yeah speaking of maintaining
the tension yeah
it didn't seem that knight c6 was going
to work out in his favor
and the whole idea of winning the light
squared bishop
you know looked right but okay knight c4
was played
and now i think it's time for uh yeah
you want to guard the b6 pawn to to make
sure that i don't have
bishop takes d5 and knight b6 although i
don't think i would anyway
because there'd always be a there might
be a possible rook v8 but um knight d7
just covers that up so that it's not an
issue to defend now there is
this one line okay i have to be careful
if i play a move like e2 e4 it's not
without consequence
my pieces on the d3 on the d-file pardon
me are suddenly weakened but i was
trying to do it with a very specific
idea in mind which was to run this pawn
up the board but the problem is i think
the d2
bishop is going to be hanging
okay
after bishop g2 king g2 bishop e5 i
think i can simply
well did you check bishop g to uh take
on f6 though we also have to look at
that oh i see i apologize i did it the
wrong way bishop e5 i apologize yes
because otherwise yeah it takes on f6
even that might not work but okay
yeah even this you mean like this takes
uh takes here
uh takes here and then again
a lot of there's a traffic
right
on the d3 on the d file
so
intriguing game here right right
everything so instead of e4 though i do
think there are some other options maybe
i can just
make a solid move like with the c1 or d1
you know earlier you had this beautiful
knight on d4 uh you sacrificed the two
bishops to get the knight on d4 but here
of course we can we can calmly put a
rook on c1
okay we have to do it in a way that we
don't lose the a4 you don't want to lose
a4
um so rook fc one yeah we're casting one
i was thinking although i see there was
like some but we've got b2 protected by
two knights right now right and you we
always have to check the uh
well even in this crazy situation
for sure there is this uh
we can force if we want the trade this
doesn't look quite as good for black
with the knight on the wrong circuit the
knight is not on d4 it's not seven our
rook just got activated too on a5
both of them right yeah so that didn't
pan out but i do have the impression
that uh
the black's okay yeah that he may he may
be able to uh slowly slowly get rid of
his pressure and some other games uh
what about
the ones that are particularly explosive
let's take a look back at aronia and
caruana maurice has the latest for us on
that all right
absolutely dominant position now for
aronian but he has to
sacrifice a rook to prove it well i'm
being a little bit over dramatic i don't
do that very often but at any rate this
position after knight takes on f5 we
knew that this was forced to take on f5
bishop c4 check now king to g7 now going
into the corner was karwana and now d5
and that's the big clamp that's like i'm
just gonna sit on your face and you're
not gonna like it who does when you sit
on somebody's face this move d5 is now
in the position and now
rook to e8 the engines really didn't
like that last move too much i thought
knight d6 just sacrificing the pawn
because this move rook to e8 allows and
here comes the
moment i was talking about knight to e4
we all know you put a knight in front of
a pawn on e4 where pawns can't challenge
it and you just have a fantastic piece
this knight is just dominating the
chessboard don't go anywhere because i
got you covered every which direction
but the great thing about this move is
knight d4 doesn't work it looks good
we're not sacrificing exchange we're
ignoring everything and sacrificing a
rook with the move queen to h5 and this
now allows for some spectacular
variations if you don't take this rook
it's going to move to f2 double rooks on
this file and you know you're going to
cry because your position is going to be
terrible g pawns hanging an attack on
your king that just looks silly right
now but if you do take the rook knight
takes on g5 you might have noticed by
the way the engine go crazy all the way
to the top because white is now winning
cold there are no variations to look at
let's take a look at the first one
borrowing a second rook i say borrowing
uh because you're actually dying queen
takes a seven check the king's gotta
move and now the knight drops back to e4
and a funky little checkmate on the
board that's out don't touch my rook uh
now we go back to this one remember that
that title yes it's title take my rooks
please that's not a good example of
taking rooks after knight takes g5 there
are other moves here bishop to f5 being
one of them white could play calmly or
kill the guy whichever one is going to
work for him if he calculates queen f7
check
the king does not want to go back into
this position because after queen takes
threatening mate with writing knight f7
the queen's hanging that's all she wrote
that's horrible uh so in this position
uh the position could go i'll just get
my position back here instead of queen
after bishop to f5
okay just when i was getting exciting my
my board decided to disappear on me i
think i can get it back but no i can't
i'm gonna have to you have to trust me
in this position after check uh bishop
f5 rook f1 yes you might want to take a
look at that because you're going to
love the variations coming out of that
line rook f1 super powerful with the
idea of rook takes the bishop on f5 rook
f7 is threatened everything is
threatening that position it's just huge
karana in deep trouble in all the main
lines but the key is he has to find 94
right now does aronia is going to take
him some time in this position on the
board to find the move knight to e4 and
confirm that he's just much better
wow
now that you've passed me the baton i
gotta carry it with it gotta go with it
okay so we've got uh this position
on the board
yeah mine is working so we're ex this is
a lovely variation knight e4
uh taking up a great strategic outpost
in the middle of the board knight d4 the
variation that maurice was pointing out
queen h5 if we capture the rook
knight takes g5 but what maurice was
saying was that after bishop f5 queen
check king h6 you don't want to go back
to h8 because if you go back to h8 queen
takes f5 so king h6 gets a little bit
wild here
i
but what maurice was saying is that
after knight takes
knight takes g5 i think maurice was
mentioning this move bishop f5 and now
rook f1
hitting this bishop
uh setting up for queen f7 check bishop
g6
bishop g6 looks forced right we're gonna
go in we get to go in with rook at seven
rook f7 check you gotta drop back with
the king there's no other choice in that
situation now we go queen h6 we've got
that
sweet little queen ethic and if you take
the knight of course i don't take your
queen
oops and i dug it g7 that was a mouth
slip everybody
oh that's pretty sweet that is a sweet
so lavon aronian of course bishop f7
just allowing queen h7 queen f7 sorry
wow
um no they just the uh rook f1 rook f1
bishop g6 so yeah that is very pretty
huh
whoops
that's all she wrote then after king
after king g8
king g8 queen h6 so now you can't play
bishop takes f7 because of queen h7 um
and
if we go back one more move we go back
one more move
um another move actually yeah oh sorry
bishop takes f7 i see what you mean we
have two options here but taking on f
a7 is the right one and king
now we have f6 four oh this is two
this is too pretty now the king uh king
caught in the in the center wow like a
little apple at mate right oh that's so
beautiful very nice oh that's really
really nice black would be forced to
give up this queen but that's that's a
little bit more than the queen right
because we also get to take on it on uh
f7 as well that would be a gorgeous
figure getting all the and getting the
check made on d7 and on top so levon
aronian really
no question about it if he goes for that
rook sacrifice he is
whoa he's got the time to think about it
right he's got a full hour here he's
been keeping great track of this clock
and is he going to note that this is a
critical moment and go for it lavon said
this is the tournament where he's going
to regain his form well he said america
is the land of opportunity and he's
looking for his opportunities and he's
got one right now
and one of the things that i think these
2800s have
that mere mortals don't is a tremendous
sense
it's like it's like their spidey sense
starts tingling when they have such
opportunities right it's that critical
moment and this is it and this is where
we think that if if lavonne
can
work his way through
that analysis that we just showed and if
he could come up with this great move
knight e4
and offering
a entire rook
sacrifice
for from a human point of view also it
feels like in this position it's even
harder to calculate because he's
probably also looking at like d6 not
just knight takes g5 right you know like
after after after um knight takes c2
yeah you definitely so that makes the
tree much more complex exactly your
bishop on c4 it's kind of looking a
little passive so you want it in the
game so you start thinking about okay
playing that move d5 d6 and like you say
it's just
wrong
but but at first you have to look at it
because you want to open up the bishop
and get control of the f7 yeah why is it
leah let's take a look and see how black
knocks that down so we can just get a
sense of what lavon might be looking at
here right so you're you're kind of
similar variations similar variations
you you're trying to take control of the
f7 square but the reality is that after
a move i don't know like maybe just
simply bishop e6
or
just moving our rook over to the
um f eight squared don't forget we have
still this guy
uh
on
right so it's pretty key to defend that
f7 f7 square
because now when we we play knight takes
g5 it's no longer a double attack
exactly so you have time to play like
bishop f5 or something like that yeah
bishop f5 h6 yeah just to put that on
the board knight takes g5 ideas like
queen h7 can be met either with h6 or as
you said jan with the move bishop f5 and
it turns out this move d5 d6 wasn't
actually needed
right we can save that for later and
yeah i mean there's still probably stuff
to analyze there but if but won't once
he sees all those uh myriad defenses for
black and yet the more forcing light
with knight g5 he will start going on
that more linear route well exactly and
when you come down to this knight g5
well you immediately reject h6 because
that's simply a checkmate in two okay
everybody gets that one but the one
that's tough and it's really tough
actually is this move bishop f5 because
that covers h7 and you've got to see
this nice little quiet move rook f1
because otherwise you can convince
yourself the variation makes no sense
until you see that after rook f1 bishop
drops back this
uh beautiful line very beautiful so we
that's i love it so
how did we do that again what we did was
happen
no no the pretty line was f instead of
bishop f7 um here bishop f7 here here
yeah because because um right now we
instead of instead of playing queen f7
playing queen h7 to start right because
queen f7 so long as the king can go to
h6 exactly he's still kicking right and
we don't want any kicking we actually
it's it's bizarre in a way i think
what's so beautiful about this is
normally we want to bring our king to
the side yeah but here actually we can't
get another piece into the attack
because the knight going to e4 is
actually further away from the deck
whereas if you look at the mirror image
it's um beautiful because we actually
get the bishop and the bonnet that's the
one i really like yeah so here instead
we play queen h7 right and isn't this
wonderful i get to steal maurice's
thunder because he had this beautiful
position he's working the line all set
up and his computer froze so i get to do
the honors oh that's well i think the
best thing of all is we if we actually
get this position on the board of course
can we go back real quick to rick f1
because i just want to see i'm sure
everything else loses by force but oh
and it's happening is it happening let's
take a look
we do have 94 on the board
and i was just wondering if after
of course fabiano's not forced to play
knight d4 right
true so if he finds it is completely
losing i was just wondering after 94
queen h5 knight c2
yes
after that whole variation after
i'm assuming there's no other moves
except for bishop g6 but after bishop f5
you mean bishop f5 now again this quiet
move rook f1 that really
shows so devastating the attackers touch
actually i like that move very much rook
f1 and again just to put one other
variation 93 defending the bishop that
won't work at all because that whole
knight e4 checkmate idea
as maurice has pointed out in other
similar situations
works
and of course you can't go back to f8
because that's
similar lines if you try to defend the
situation with the rook on f8
exactly and then what about what about
with the queen so what if we play queen
c8
or queen f6 queen c8 okay yeah oh yeah
queen f6 or queen c8 exactly probably
queen f6 looks
a little bit more necessary right
because yeah okay so let's put queen f6
on the board oops excuse me i'm making
two moves for black queen f6
is hanging here well that's precisely
right
and that's a big diff right i can take
the rook
but now you've got to take the knight
yeah of course we have to play queen g5
here okay but now i can take this pawn
on e5 with a check and we're just going
to be up material at the end of that
wow we're going to be working yeah
our defending champion in serious
trouble in round one against levon
aronia that's right he does look like um
he's not enjoying this and he i think
he's going to try to find something
besides knight before but what else is
there exactly maurice what's your
thoughts
troublesome position certainly for
fabiano fans that one there after 94
lavon looks like he's just on top of the
world we saw that position after the
trade the premature trade
not maintaining the tension by chiron or
rookie coming or way too late and he is
well aware of the fact that he's in deep
trouble this position is just terrible
white is just standing pretty and
aronian just has to pressure the game
right now you see him standing there
picking up his cup and saying i'm just
going to go for a stroll and drink here
meantime a completely different posture
for caruana who's just
clearly under massive pressure after
such creative play in the opening
speaking of creative play let's get to
another position where our number one
player on the planet magnus carlson has
played a quite unusual move the move
here after knight to b6 he played bishop
to h5
going after that pawn on f7 it's not
every day you see a bishop come from h5
trying to attack the f7 square
we're seeing all kinds of new things
here but this one not exactly new but
certainly different from what we
normally see well here the engine's
saying that's nothing what are you
talking about we're going to first start
by trading and here if black were
totally scared black could just rip this
knight off right now remember he has a
piece in his hand so rook takes g5 is
playable followed by nibbling on this
pawn on d4 and he's keeping it with the
move e5 coming soon but the engine is
also saying i can also be just greedy
i'll play rook to g6 and dare you to
find a continuation here
natural looks to be queen takes a seven
and now rook g7 covering the f7 point
attacking the queen queen h8 is possible
and now show me what you got after
taking on d4 now there is a move here
knight to 8-7 most natural attacking
move and now the engine's saying i'll
take you now get rid of that and play e5
and in this position white is even in
material i could argue that he has a
rook and a pawn for a knight and bishop
even in material but hey this past pawn
that bishop bishop going to be able to
go to e6
now it's starting to look quite nice for
black the pressure on this side plus the
pass pawn plus the two pieces for the
rook but maybe this is what magnus has
to go into and say you know i can try to
make something of this position my pawn
going down the board and maybe some
compensation the engines say no
the rook maybe on the cfa maybe some
compensation
this is a bit messier position and
something that black can argue he has uh
he has a great advantage but maybe not
clear and easy to win so topalov is
going to have to decide which direction
he wants to go in here and magnus knows
that he is in trouble
he can't believe that he's perfectly
okay after this full sacrifice of a
piece you know if magnus had the black
pieces he'd be thinking
i don't believe you i'm going to find a
way to win so now it's up to topalov to
face the pressure of a desperate
champion the last we saw in the grand
chess tour magnus went down horribly
against his countrymen and and friend
john los vega
he doesn't want to continue the trend in
the first round as he lost the last
first round against topalov this would
be a horrible start to say the least for
the world champion thank you maurice i
mean those are some very nice variations
that
black
plays to
how do you say break the pressure but
the really annoying thing if you're in
vessel in topolof shoes is that you've
won a piece out of the opening
and now you're thinking to yourself i've
got this game won
and your opponent you know
darnam he's he's really making it
difficult and you saw vessel and
toppolov saying why is it this guy has
so much compensation this move bishop h5
is really a move off the beaten path you
might see that in some beginners games
where you might jump in and say you know
you really shouldn't be trying to attack
the bishop you know the f7 pawn from the
side of the board you're supposed to put
it on the italian diagonal you know a2
f7 but that movement bishop h5 is really
annoying to
tip off okay obviously you should take
that bishop
queen takes rook up now
i'm i really don't like this move queen
takes h7 of course i like winning a pawn
but if i'm in white shoes i'm thinking
that you got to play take on d4 take on
c5 and just try to open up the position
so that you'll bring your bishop into
the game quickly followed by rook d1 i
believe
something has happened that's right
we've got uh the variation we looked at
on the board in the game between aronia
and karana what happened maurice
incredible we thought that he had to
hunker down and just try to defend the
position but carano went right ahead
with this move knight to d4 incredibly
allowing queen to h5 and it's like a
snowball rolling down the hill the
position is busted it's out he cannot
take this rook we know that for a fact
the engine is giving the only move to be
bishop to f5 just to try to hang on but
it's the engine is also saying this is
lost this is a horrible position to have
after the move rook to f2 white's pieces
just look beautiful like how could he
dream of a better position bishop back
to g6 is playable here but now queen to
g4 forget about trading we're not
trading yet i mean grabbing this pawn
and trying to trade going to some end
game we're just going to keep this
position and make you suffer h5 is
possible begging him to he could take if
he wants to begging him no no you're
still on the pressure we want to take
this with the knight and this position
is slowly but truly turning into a total
mess if bishop takes e4 trying to get
rid of that strong knight rook takes and
now the rooks the bishop black's pieces
look awful e pawn is hanging and don't
play this move right here queen e7
trying to defend it because d6 will land
on the board with rook to f7 coming this
might be the line to play something here
queen d6
is also possible in this position no
it's not because the queen takes g5 so
what to do after
queen h5 going back here
how could carolina go into this line and
hope that he's going to survive this is
busto this is out like gone and he is in
deep trouble the winner of last year's
syncfield cup the engines are giving
plus three i mean three is
you don't even play you don't even make
moves it doesn't look
like like material is being won to that
degree as yet but clearly
white is completely on top and aronian
knows it remember he was just strolling
a second ago now he's gone into no more
games i've got to get you i will not let
you off the hook and i'm going to take
home this win amazing how
easy it is to play this kind of we
talked about 21st century chess and then
one slip and you go back into a nice
little 20th century beatdown
that's what's happening here well you
know aronian is famous for trash talking
and if only he could talk now in fact he
should go into the confessional
do a little trash talking but uh indeed
this is this is beautiful but you know
maybe fabiano missed something in some
of those variations
some of them not not that easy to see
ever that quiet move maybe rook f1 he
missed is that possible that does seem
pretty forcing it's not that quiet of a
move is it
i don't know maybe bishop maybe he
missed something with bishop g6 rook f7
maybe he was looking at the variation
with uh queen takes h7 instead of i mean
queen takes f7 king h6 instead of queen
eight seven right these are things that
it's human to match oh easily oh yeah
because there's a lot of other
variations
he has to check other things the
problems the engine tells us what the
best move is so we look along that
branch yeah but whereas for him he has
to look at every brand because he's not
like able to see it that quickly and
that's what's difficult being able to
look at all of those branches then
figuring out the decisive one then
getting it all right exactly not easy um
and i think he missed something there
well i mean you just mentioned uh
levon should go into the uh confessional
and i'm thinking that isn't that's the
wrong thing to do because it's like
hubris you know you go into the
confessional and say i'm winning i'm
winning i'm winning and then you get
smackdown because you miss a move or
something of that nature but it's
awesome that's an awesome time to use a
confessional when you're winning right
now it's like it's a cute game for the
confessional what that doesn't mean you
only do it when you play badly i think
when players win they should go in there
and
brag too i mean because in a way if he's
totally winning then he doesn't have to
worry about
wasting time in the confessional or
getting out of the zone right so i think
now would be the time to do it all right
interesting uh a little discreet we've
got a and we've got an update um do we
have a move in the game um
maurice has a comment in the game do we
gotta move
no i have a comment on your comment the
business about the confessional i have
to tell you a story that you'll see who
i agree with in this situation many
years ago i was playing against grand
master robert byrne long time writer for
the new york times
and
robert of course is a
famous player was a famous player i mean
he was at the end of some bobby fischer
brilliancies and i was a young player
not even an im yet and i was doing
really well in the world open i think it
was
going way back 1988 or 89 and i'm
playing this position with the black
pieces and i'm just all over him in like
20 moves i'm crushing him unbelievable
that with the black piece and sicilian
that's what i was doing and i'm
strolling around feeling pretty good
about myself and a friend of mine
natasha us who's now natasha christensen
married to grandmaster larry christensen
she saw me looking with that cheshire
cat smile on my face and she said uh
what's going on and i said to her with
all the hubris in the world
i'm gonna get a brilliancy for this game
like just like that like i was so proud
of myself the way i was just beating on
it
and she said she wide-eyed really wow
she was surprised i go back to the board
and on the very next move i missed the
crushing blow on the very next move i
had lost my concentration my focus just
thinking this is over i miss the win on
that move and he proceeded after he's
he's like oh you missed it to start
torturing me for the next 30 moves and
now i was the one who was suffering and
then in that moment when i was suffering
30 moons later i defended myself i was
okay and instead of taking a draw he got
hubris he got filled and said i'm not
giving this punk a draw and made a
mistake and i was able to pull off a
tricky combination and win the game
anyway
after the game i was kicking myself and
i think that i now will tell you i agree
with yasser i think it's a poor time
when you when you think you're winning
to go start talking trash you need to
focus on putting somebody out because
chess punishes us time and time again
when we get cocky in the middle of the
game to me you're not winning until the
person
reaches their hand over says i'm i
resigned that's it i i don't think about
winning anymore that taught me a lesson
play the game be true to the game be
true to the moment because chess
sometimes you're winning but you got to
play spectacular moves and when your
mind starts wandering that's when you
miss ideas
don't listen to the players we want
everybody to use the confessional box at
every opportunity
because it is tough for them to use it
yeah so i think they're more prone to
use the confessional box after they made
a mistake and then they want everybody
to recognize you're gonna lose anyway
we've got some other big news
in another game
uh well let's take a look uh has fabiano
made a move yet
let's let's refresh the board on
fabiano's board and has he played knight
to d4 he's taking it he's taken the
route he's taking
this knight takes g5
probably bishop f5 rook f1 gorgeous
variation and i mean talk about
brilliancies
this is the one that really had assumed
this is going to be i was i was
postulating that perhaps earlier fabiano
missed this queen takes um h7 and was
mostly analyzing queen takes f7 because
i mean that is kind of the move that
strikes you first of course of course
you're right you take a bishop over a
pawn but then king h6 and yeah probably
fabiano's discovered some defensive
way of holding this position that would
be my gut that he started looking and
then he started looking maybe a queen f5
and he went down the rabbit hole or
something that's that's a problem
sometimes when you start looking too
long at one variation without stepping
back and seeing if you missed a fork in
the road yeah that can happen quite a
lot my overview but this was the uh the
lovely
uh queen h7 check driving the king into
the check and then the best move is
after king e7 because come on you can't
screw it up now maurice and ryan you
gotta agree with me now now run to the
confessional booth
before poppy has a chance to play king
e7
i love it okay okay you got a point
there you know when you can see it made
in three you know okay you got a four
yeah and just again this is this is the
spl beautiful mom wouldn't do that yeah
lavon is a great guy he's he understands
the importance of popularizing chess and
i think in theory he would do that under
some circumstances except it might be a
bit too painful to fobby we'll see right
also uh just the confessional thing i
remember this i played in a u.s
championship
and uh i was just cruising i was doing
great in the u.s championship and i was
playing against alexander shabalov
and shibalov just had a terrible
position and if i win this game i'm
i i've clinched a championship
and
literally i relaxed
and the game turned around in time
trouble i lost i ended up tying for
first but i remember grandmaster larry
christensen coming up to us in the
post-mortem and say uh at this moment
yes sir i think you were writing your
victory speech
i love it yeah i got it no but you you
don't have a flare for long speeches
so knight takes g5 has that been that
has been played an hour awaiting a
fabiano's response and okay well this
game's not going to be a long one and
for those of us who were
you know predicting or hoping for a
fabiano uh streak part two in the
sinkhole cop
it doesn't look like we're gonna get it
if anything he um now has to um get out
of the hole after this game but one
other game that i'm sure we're gonna
have a very close eye on after the
result for this one comes in is geary
versus grisha because one of our
tweeters we do have our hashtag sync cup
um so if you have comments you should
also put them in but um one of our
tweeters mentioned that um
there must be a broadcast there because
the times are wrong in yuri grishok
yeah the times are clearly wrong 11
minutes for griezhook and one in 28 for
gary except no
they are right there exactly
unfortunately it's believable because uh
the really tragic thing about sasha is
he is addicted to trying time trouble he
loves
somehow being under that intense
pressure of the the clock but be very
careful don't try to blitz him off
because he's one of the world's greatest
blitz players and if you try to take
advantage of his time trouble by playing
fast moves on top of his moves he's
going to outduel you in that that's
right so that's going to be really
exciting to watch and i do like gary's
position on to boot so
down on time alexander agree shook and
we are going to have to see him remember
there's no increment in this first time
control so
20 moves in 11 minutes so an average of
30 seconds to move no hey that's not
that bad but guess what he has to figure
out how to rationate himself whereas if
we were playing in a tradition on time
control it would be rationed for him
with the 30-second moment that's right
so
interesting um
developments ahead in that game and
meanwhile in uh seoul maxine bashiro de
what's what's up maurice where do we
where do they stand in their match every
single game when you look at these
tournaments now in the modern era
someone had asked me like what's the
difference between now and the past now
because of these anti-draw rules and the
advent of players like magnus carlson
and nakamura the fighting chess spirit
is so alive and in every single game
we're seeing incredible action and just
explosive chess as a fan you've got to
love it that this is happening
especially organizers making sure the
players know we're not playing paying
big money for you to make easy draws now
take a look at this position here
between wesley seoul and vashila grav
wesley had grabbed the pawn in the
opening we saw that and now after queen
c2 bishop e6 knight to c3 trot that's
the fourth move by that knight by the
way this knight is the one that was on
f3 to start the game just for your
information so this knight is just
dancing around and trying to hold this
side of the board what did vasila graf
say
no there is no rest for the weary here i
come i'm going to sacrifice yet another
pawn to be able to play moves like
knight to b4 uh let's just show you what
would have happened here after
well i think the opening is has gone
well for me i was not 100 sure
about
how to remember my preparation and so on
but
this point sacrifice seems
to me
to give
good compensation unlike some of the
sacrifices i've done in the past this
this one seems
sander let's say and
well now with bishop f5 i'm
probably
forcing a concession out of iceland
probably with e4 or
moving the queen but
in any case i will have great
compensation for the opponent
i
don't think i should be so much better
but
in practical player
it seems my
my position is much easier to play
all right we had a quick change there
because maxine vashila grav talking
about this exact game he went into this
line and he thinks that he's not much
better but he thinks he has compensation
i think that's code for i think i'm much
better
but again you don't want to brag too
much about your position so he's just
giving a general evaluation of his
thought patterns and keeping himself as
calm as possible in this position when
you know you have an edge you know it's
clear but you don't want to get too
happy again when you have these
opportunities b5 now the spectacular
move he played in this position
sacrificing a pawn but again we
understand taking that pawn knight's
going to drop to b4 the threat on the a2
pawn all kinds of action so instead
bishop takes c6 getting tired of that
night like i just can't stand it anymore
you got to kill that piece but
every english player knows you're giving
up your g2 bishop it's like whoa are you
serious well b takes on c6 still with
the threat of b4
clinging to that pawn i can't believe
how materialistically wesley soul has
played this game and after this move
bishop to f5 attacking the queen and you
just see these killer bees pointing all
the way down the position e4 was coming
soon and if you get
happy and say well i'll just attack your
bishop well now your king will not leave
the middle of the board this bishop is
super strong and black still has
everything his queen can come rook
double on this far play for f5 the two
bishops the light square bishop in
particular
a super strong position for black full
compensation the engine's actually
saying to maxime no it's not just a
little compensation you're much better
even though you're down a pawn here it
is all black in the driver's seat and
wesley's so clinging for his life uh and
you can see it there
not a happy camper staring at this
position as wesley and he's been doing
so for some time so a bad bad start to
what really was
not forgivable play in the way he went
and grabbed the pawn in the opening
moving all those pieces uh was he so
will be suffering for some time to come
in this game
meanwhile we have seen bishop to f5 by
fabiano caruana so we're waiting to um
see lavonne make this spectacular move
or rook to f1
and here he is
uh that a long
gulf of water
burying himself of the world
he's played the beautiful move um
fabiano
knew that was coming always always has
that poker face but
i i don't know did you detect the little
psy there
i did
i did and uh one of the things that i've
when lavonne is informed
and he was the number two player in the
world a dominant player one of the
wonderful things about lavonne is he has
this fantastic calculating uh tactical
attacking style and when he's in the the
flow so to speak
uh he's he's an unstoppable force and
right now he's
really really happy he's feeling like a
million bucks too that's a great thing
lavon allows himself to enjoy
the um beauty of of chess of art i mean
that's important because how hard are we
on ourselves when we lose exactly he is
going to be
smiling tonight indeed and um he left
the board so he must be going to the
confession although that's right no i
think he's just
shaking off the cobwebs a little bit
nervous but all equally also very
confident let's turn to our
number one table because again after
this move bishop h5 this very annoying
move i saw
topalovi shaking his head like you know
why does this guy have anything any kind
of pressure but it's clear you've got to
eliminate that bishop which he did do
queen takes and this is where i like
that line that maurice
uh showed us which was this rook g6 line
you could play of course rook takes g5
as he mentioned
and then capture this pawn on d4 but i
like this
little in
swisson zug if you will to gain a few
tempe
and do it in this fashion
and this looked very very nice in my
estimation for black
again
materially speaking white isn't doing
that bad but this is ideal position for
the minor pieces there's not a lot of
open ranks for the rooks
to utilize
excuse me
seven
which i think is the secondary
move
and now again i'm thinking that what
magnus has got to do is take this pawn
on c5 and after the recapture to bring
his bishop out and say look
this may be a little bit
okie dokie intuitive kind of play but
i'm going to play to trap your king in
the center i'm going to play bishop f4
i'm going to bring my rook on d1 i'm
going to try to put as much pressure on
you as i can and
hopefully
you will make a mistake if you're under
pressure by the way i just like to show
one neat little trick for a second after
bishop f4 let's say rook a7 i just have
to show this because this is a nice one
rook d1 rook d7 it looks like black has
gotten everything covered but wait a
minute
96
and i can
pick off this rook with a check
and
white is in the game why i mean it's not
that
black is going to claim victory with his
extra piece
so it's just a very an annoying game for
vessel and topology but instead nathan's
h7 is on the board knight takes h he
took he didn't take on c5 no he
played indeed
then i'm surprised by the aha okay there
is knight f8 and bishop h6
happening sorry i was thinking that
this
would
but no this is it's queen h8 and bishop
h6 right precisely so you don't have
time to take
on d4 right away but you have to perhaps
you have to do it another way if you're
vessel and perhaps you have to capture
the knight but then you don't have the
tempo that uh
that rook g6 would have given you so
this clearly
isn't as good as the
the previous line of g6 so now so now we
don't have the movie five in so that's
the difference right so it's white to
move here and
the question is what should they do to
try to keep the position again and i
think maurice does this really well he
says look
you've got to use your trumps
yeah i mean whatever your trumps may be
otherwise you're just going to lose and
in this position white's trumps are the
rooks and he's got to
open up the position uh
well either it's the immediate e5
immediately to open up the position for
the rooks or how about this one how
about a4 with the idea of the rook lift
and bringing that guy across to get that
takes a lot of moves unfortunately by by
the time you get in these three tempos
black
will
figure out a defensive uh scheme
but
magnus is going to have to do something
of that nature if not e5
that's right so definitely some
something about practical chances here
for magnus and
just lots of lots of interesting choices
um so obviously keeping a close eye on
this game meanwhile looks like
fabiano carolina still
struggling after the move worked to f1
he's still thinking
but i mean it's there's not a lot of
options here right we looked at it
before um
queen of six just hangs on e8 bishop g6
loses by force
what do you think he's going to do here
uh
i think he's going to go down in the
blaze of glory that's right that's right
he's going to be he's going to make it
beautiful whatever it is
well he wants to make it beautiful
bishop g6 is the way to go that's right
that's definitely the prettiest line
that is definitely pretty considering it
loses absolutely by force so whereas
some of the other moves you're only you
have to resign but
the problem is as one you're on the
losing end of the brilliancy it can't
help but go through your mind gosh darn
it i'm going to be in the next you know
200 books published on chess tactics you
know if there's going to be a chapter
on a game like this like and too bad for
fabi's point of view that when he beat
aronian it was also a spectacular
wonderful game but not quite as flashy
yeah exactly but that was that was a
great game last year the game that he
won was white against aranya yeah also a
classic so these these two gates can go
like side by side and the best thing
field cup hits i tell you they they
really take the measure of one another
maurice
and this one could actually be this one
could actually be even more spectacular
than all that because the move the
engines by the way are saying okay the
best move and just do a little bit of
engine uh speak here the engine's saying
the best move is queen f6 and white has
a 9.68 edge 9 is a queen up we know what
a queen is valued right so queen of six
i could go up as much as a queen
advantage i'll look at that move in a
second but the second move on the
engines list is queen to d6 and the
advantage it gives
i just don't ever see this number show
up the advantages against the queen d6
without saying it's mate
63.93
is that is there that much material in
chess if you add it all up i think the
number is 39. so how do you get to 63.93
who's programming this stuff i mean
that's you that should just be like we
don't want to talk about it it's it's
blood it's too it's too ugly to discuss
but here the move queen f6
you guys pointed out this move queen to
f6 that this move is possible and queen
takes e8 well rook takes f5 is even
worse like boom another sacrifice
showing up because after queen takes f5
let's just drop this 96 check on you
yummy yummy give me your queen so this
position is just horrible to contemplate
uh rookie six queen e5 it's just you're
dropping the knight on c2 in the world
in the least case if the guy decides to
be nice to you and just just play around
with you for a while so that move would
not be playable rook takes f5 there's
this move queen g6 finally coming to the
aid of the king uh uh stopping this line
this is a variation he might have looked
at thinking that he might somehow be
okay in this position but rook f7 check
king back to g8 and is he really alive
well there are lots of ways to play here
d6 happens to be one of them wouldn't
that be nice look at that move d6
whew that just looks sexy i mean
seriously you're going to get killed on
this long diagonal sacrificing the queen
he might play this move even though it's
not the best one when you come to think
of it because because it just looks so
good and it's absolutely crushing if you
dare to touch the queen then you're
gonna run into this move d7 and
this is impossible is this real chess i
mean look at this position this is
hanging the rook is going to come around
win the queen at any point don't check
me because i'll discover check your back
i mean it's just an enormous position
for white like you said this is the kind
of position that's going to make it into
the books and poorer caruana is at the
losing end of this brilliancy
thank you maurice uh some
uh great great variations there for uh
lavone and
it's going to go into his greatest hits
collection uh let me go back to that
game between anish geary and um
alexander grisham for a moment because
even though
the time
is so one-sided in favor of uh anish
gary i just want to point out
that everybody would love to play this
move uh knight d5 because you're picking
up a tempo against the queen oops sorry
that arrow wasn't very good and if you
play queen a4
you just end up dropping the bishop and
resigns
however
what black will do and he'll do it
instantly and he'll be very very happy
is to sacrifice his queen
captures the knight captures and what
comes off the board a queen comes off
the board but a rook a minor piece and a
pawn has come off the board for
white and in fact black's position is
very solid and it's a kind of position
that
um
grisha can play very very very quickly
he would be delighted uh if anish went
down this road to win the queen so
in the absence of that move knight d5
what could anish do to improve his
position well he could play the move 95
picking up a tempo against his pawn on
c6
and as he gets defended with the move
rook on f8 to c8 again you kind of feel
a near obligation to play the move
knight d5 you've got to
do something with this queen on a3
otherwise for the moment uh black has
maintained an extra pawn and if you
don't do anything well the queen would
retreat withdraw i mean and then play
what about c5 what about playing knight
to uh b5 instead of playing nate d5
so should we include 95 uh
not sure yeah maybe because then we
think on a7 we're attacking the rook i
don't know though exactly okay so we'll
just toss in this move knight b-5 my
idea here is that this the queen
sacrifice not quite as powerful when you
don't have that uh that grip on the
center that you did when picking you
yeah the beautiful structure exactly
yeah well let's have a look so i will
capture
the knight you will capture my queen
i will recapture your rook so again i
have that same material and balance of
minor piece
rook and palm for the queen
but at the moment again it's pretty easy
to play black it's not like the king is
coming under a direct attack and i've
got these ideas of just advancing
the pawns up the board
and this is a game that in time trouble
could go either way it's not
completely over for anish
maurice
another game that explosions are going
on is the game between wesley so and
maxine vashti lagrav in this position we
were saying that e4 bishop h3 looks
yummy for black but take a look at what
happened d3 and now these two bishops
you know they just like stood up
straight when that move happened and the
move e4 landed on the board
now opening up the full diagonal for the
other bishop
wesley took immediately and now a couple
of options were possible here queen d4
is possible but the move he instead
played was bishop takes on e4 thanks for
the pawn now of course you can't take
back with the queen because of that move
bishop takes on c3 and that's all she
wrote it's all over now but instead he
played bishop takes e4 he just simply
took back knight takes on e4 and now
bishop takes a1 and this is the position
we have white has a knight and a pawn
for the exchange he's an exchange down
but he's hoping
and i think it's called it's really
hoping that somehow he's going to get
some compensation black has a great
position here the bishop can always drop
back if your bishop lands on h6 if you
do something simple like castling well
the queen centralizes itself the rooks
are coming yes this just looks
really really good for black and so
vashia lagrav has now won his material
back i think if you were to go to the
confessional booth that he'd be very
happy here
big development in the other game
however i was going to talk about the
magnus game that that game is big but
before we go to that this i want to make
sure we don't miss a game after queen of
six lavon missed rook takes on a five
instead he played a move that is also
winning knight to e6 with check uh this
move is crushing as well it's gonna be
one of those things you say oh man i
should have hit you with with the right
but i hit you with the left and it was
like a little i kind of hit but you're
still going down it comes to hitting
you're hitting you're hitting you 96 has
happened and uh the bishop on f5 is
clearly hanging the move the engine is
giving rook takes on e6 now rook takes
and this also looks completely crushing
that's hanging rook g5 the queen
it's also busted a good human move 96
and lavon just getting up right there he
knows it's over
poor
fabi in round one to just go down in
flames like this uh let me now and he
actually has taken on e6 so let's stay
with this game because it looks like
it's about to be over soon that's right
we have seen roof takes e600 to f5
um lavon quickly run into the
conventional booth
just wishful thinking on my part because
it would be fun funny except not so
funny for fabiano
who um might find himself in one of
those awkward situations where he wants
to resign but he needs to wait for his
opponent to come back
okay quick question for you jen queen g6
uh you got the choice you could play you
know you're winning you know you got the
game in hand would you take the rook or
would you go rook to g5 to take the
queen what would you do choices choices
choices choices
um let's see
both are winning
i'm just thinking i'm just asking is a
matter of personal aesthetics well no no
personal aesthetics and preference yeah
well i mean this does seem like the kind
of game that you want to you want to
finish with the checkmate so rook g5
okay interesting i i i could go either
way i was mentally flipping a coin
myself i think the more practical is it
if you if you're a time pressure like if
you're agree and you've gone in this
position you've got five seconds left to
make ten moves then you probably take on
e6 right right that's what i was
thinking i was thinking okay if you take
on e6 one of the things
that makes this so good for white
is that you could answer move for
example in this position rook c5 move e7
and oops and end in a pretty way and
that ends in a pretty way so and look at
nakamura with that beautiful red shirt
that's i think that's a stinky cup shirt
he's watching fabiano um
and he's thinking
getting even solidifying my board one
position on the u.s olympic team
are the americans rooting for one
another i think in a way yeah i think i
mean i don't know maybe some are more
than others but
i think it the higher all of them get
the better chances they have to win the
olympiad and that's huge but at the same
time these guys are competition each
other um for becoming visually and
becoming world champion or becoming a
world champion candidate exactly so
i don't know i that would be hard to say
i think in public of course they're
rooting for each other privately
and that's something that will be hard
to ever know right exactly because that
elite level of chess
magnus carlsen said in an interview
um right here at the chess club that he
doesn't think two players in the top ten
can really work together
it didn't work very well for car puffing
because he did some work with lavon
before this event and now lavon is going
to catapult back into the top 10.
so there you go okay well i must say
that for myself i really enjoyed playing
in tournaments especially european
events with my american colleagues and i
always wanted them to do really well i
always thought it would be really cool
if americans were to take high top
prizes and again the play the game the
moves of being are coming in
um he took on e6 and you took that just
to snap the rook off
oh he just recaptured the rook and now
he's staying at the board yes he didn't
capture the bishop he captured the rook
no no no no he took the bishop first
and then queen g6 and takes on e6
occurred
okay so he did it so he didn't play rook
g5 as he took the rook
maurice uh would you have made rook g5
or what have you captured the rook
well i do have the benefit of the engine
helping me here so i don't know that i
can answer that question well especially
since a former 28 30 player did not play
the two best moves on the board and
he's not going to be proud of the way
this has transpired he played great he
played just great moves to get here but
now he's played subpar moves to get what
is going to be a winning position but
not as winning as it should have been
take a look at this we saw that in this
position knight to e6 check was not the
best move after queen f6 rook takes on
f5 was all she wrote lights out busted
but he played 96 which is also all she
wrote lights out busted just not at the
same intensity of of light
in that position you get what i mean
after rook takes e6 rook takes at five
okay this is out this is crazy this is
busted queen g6 the best move by far was
rook to g5 just pin the queen in the
position and threaten to take this rook
right now why because now when you drop
the rook back here comes the move you
didn't want to see bam i didn't want
your queen yet i'll get it later what
are you going to do about this this is a
mating attack i'm going to take you with
my bishop the only move the only move
to continue is e5 you can't just play
queen takes rook i'll take with check
and then take your knight but e4 i mean
e4 is on the board and now i take your
knight and now i'll take your queen and
this is just over so he missed the most
compelling line by far this is just cold
cut winning instead after
after this move queen to g6 he took on
e6 and
queen takes
rook takes and now
he's up
what is it one pawn it's a heck of a
pawn it's pass it's crushing knight d4
is playable right now and after the move
e7 he'll have to drop back and bam
thanks for the second pawn still
crushing and threatening to queen rook
here will be forced and clearly this is
a winning end game we see that there's
no question
but you know what this could last uh
another way 15 moves i mean he's clearly
crushing him but it's not what it was
and and it's not a brilliancy and he's
not going to go down except for those
couple of moves he played with
queen i mean i guess he still will be
very proud of the game but boy he had
some vicious lines when he goes to look
at it he's going to look at it privately
he might come here and when i ask him
say yeah you know it was complicated i'm
not sure i should have gone for that but
i played the line that is clearly
winning you know practically and he's
going to go to his room and be like
idiot why didn't i play those moves that
would have been sweet and you see anand
there inspecting the board
inspecting the moves himself wondering
what happened here
not as not as crispy let's say this one
will not go down as one of the epic
attacks in history in my opinion
you know when we look at epic attacks
this will not go down as one of them
there were some variations that were
there but he didn't finish the job and
we'll we'll like it we'll like the
variations that could have happened but
i don't i wouldn't vote for
top games of the year no i'm gonna spoil
the brilliancy is what maurice is saying
and very very very very agree to the
full extent because all the juice and
the beauty it became in the earlier part
of the game and then like to go for a
position that's like plus three like
where you're totally winning and you're
gonna win 99.9
of the time and then why does that
really matter as much as i mean i
understand like the best would be if it
ended in the bishop g6 or crafts online
oh sure sure but i i i feel like i'd
give it more of a pass it's not as
beautiful but i still think it goes in
the magazines and i don't dock it as
many points for that because i think
once we get past that moment where he
plays a beautiful rook at one we we get
that aesthetic satisfaction right
because this is this this is like no no
as the artist of me i want to crisp
clean whatever makes it perfect yeah
well yeah sometimes it's a practical
matter but you know we've got more
interesting news by the way yes yes sir
um in the gary agree shirt game yuri
agreed with you i think that he didn't
think those lines with the um
winning the extra questions
were that great the way to go so instead
he played a move vert takes b6 with the
idea of knight a4 instead
so this is why rook takes b6 this
doesn't allow those
that's uh that uh queen exactly
a return okay so instead he's actually
just trading right i mean he won in
exchange you know he's going to win the
exchange back
except the question here is what's going
on with the queen queen d6
falls into e5 right right 96 is not
not good because you can take take and
play e5 and then
well
he's got what one or two pawns uh i
think the key move here is going to be
this
move c3
i think this is going to be the key move
because the point is
is okay obviously i i blocked this
attack against my queen and i'm trying
to give my queen a square after for
example rook takes queen back
i'm about to trade queens and then i'll
be off the hook right well you are off
the hook here well am i
what's the body count it's still a nice
extra pawn for white yeah white's going
to be happy
i mean i have to play some move like
queen b5 or something
so i think that this was a this is a
better play by gary and uh and meanwhile
um
time um
seven minutes left to complete um 16
moves so but he is kind of on track at
least
he remembered i'm not sure about that
we had uh i'm trying and we're going to
take a quick commercial break and then
we're going to be right back with some
more news on
magnus clausen's game as well all right
hi i'm mike matheny st louis fans are
used to championships and watching some
of the best baseball players compete at
the highest level
beginning august 23rd st louis can watch
the best chess players in the world as
10 of the top players match up with the
2015 sync field cut
fans can watch all the action in person
at the chess club and scholastic center
of st louis located in the historic west
end or by watching online at
grandchester.com
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't want to
skip st louis is the stop for non-stop
find so much fun for your family
infinity plus a ton there's museums full
of art and super fun slides upside down
concrete's twisty turny rides
some with houses
gardens growing flowers
so much fun for your family infinity
plus a ton
and we are back at the 2015 syncfield
cop
we see the camera zooming in on the
lavon oronion
uh beautiful
uh game against fabiano ocarina where
you miss the most incisive finish but
still seems to be headed towards victory
in this game meanwhile our world
champion
um battling it versus a vessel in top
lava what do you think we saw a couple
different ways for him to get um a play
and uh
which one did he pay well the peace
buyer p sacrifice by magnus was
certainly inspired and he got a lot more
out of it than he really should have as
it turns out
rook g7 really
lost a very vital tempo maurice had been
offering analysis by the computer
earlier in this game that when queen g6
queen h7
only now rook g7 queen h8 and taking
and he showed
i think very uh clearly that this line
of play was going to be excellent for
vesco instead
after the move rook g7 this just allowed
white to get back into the game knight
takes h7
queen d7
angling for ideas like queen h3 as well
as queen g4
uh and do we have takes on c5 um sorry
to interrupt but i think we might have a
finish in the carolina game is how is it
going um
let's take a look at it and the
handshake handshake has resigned so last
year's think field cup champion fabiano
carolina has gone down to somebody who's
been struggling the finance forum and
even dropped out of the top ten but wow
um what a beautiful game which might
actually just bring him back up well
let's just find out what those last
moves were maurice if you could take us
through those the last few moves of this
uh scintillating round one brilliancy
yes yes you know
jen was trying you know jenna has a soft
heart so she's like no no we
got to give it back to lev this was a
good game on his part he missed a few
wins but he's still winning it's that
kind of game well it seems as though
faviano decided to give back some
artistry to to lev in winning this game
instead of a boring end game which could
have transpired from this position
tonight under attack had to go to b3 his
only move then the king would come into
f2 is the best move and slow but sure uh
this is slowly but surely this is over
instead he played instantaneous suicide
like i'm gonna go down right now forget
suffering let me just play this move
knight to f5 and bam lavon jumped on him
so quickly with this move bishop to e6
attacking the knight now you can't touch
the pawn because hello bishop to d7 and
give me a free piece or the rook
in this position instead after bishop to
e6 he played knight d6 thinking maybe he
was still in this attacking the rook and
attacking the pawn but levon with the
beautiful bishop d7 anyway and after a
knight takes bishop takes hey let me go
get that pawn
sure you can have it but just give me
your knight in the meantime bishop to g6
a beautiful finish threatening to queen
threatening the knight nothing can help
here even if you drop your knight back
then queens anyway and you're going to
lose a piece so he resigned a beautiful
finish rightfully so after playing such
wonderful chess did levon aronian an
amazing first game and at least for
lavonne for kharani is going to kick
himself with not maintaining the tension
at critical moment when he should have
played rookie eight in the middle game
well uh
a nice finish a nice finish to a very
very very
well played game by lavonna a great win
impact
uh for lavon and hopefully we'll get him
uh
the players to join us in the meanwhile
going back to the vessel and topple off
magnus or rather magnus carlson vessel
and topalov game
the players have reached this position
and a very strange move
uh for me at least was this move e4 e5
okay from one point of view i can
understand this idea that you want to
play e6 and take advantage of this pin
and maybe maybe there's even some dirty
little check like knight f6 that we have
to contend with but i'm thinking why on
earth would you want to play that move
when you could when you allow
black choices queen f5
queen h3
and even queen g4 are all moves that
will eventually force after lots of
trades knight takes f8 and bishop h6
and maybe you don't want that pawn on e5
maybe the pawn was good on e4 so i think
magnus
uh
slipped
uh
it's a significant slip i
i mean to suggest this move e5 oh and
what a rich position with uh so many
moves left to make and only 30 minutes
in no increment this is going to hit
very wild meanwhile we've got
grandmaster maurice ashley with fabiano
carolina
and
he's here to discuss
uh disappointing start to the 2015 sing
field cup
we are with
fabulous fabi who this game uh didn't
work out for him he won all those games
last year but this start karana you
played a great
at least interesting opening we were
really impressed by the pawn moves the
unusual pawn structure but at some point
the game slipped away from you where did
that happen
um yeah i'm not sure round f3 was very
complicated i'm not sure if a4 was the
best move i could also play g4 i'll move
17
and then e5 92 e5 and we get a similar
position
um the engines thought you were okay in
that line as well yeah maybe that was
the best way to play because this i
i started to get a bit uncomfortable and
i think taking in rook a5 is not good um
i actually forgot that for some reason i
was looking at after knight takes a 5 d5
immediately but not bishop c4 check and
then d5
and this is just very strong
um
yeah i think he played very well after
that
were you you know when we see these kind
of structures that are unusual uh you
know we get uncomfortable right it's
like wait can black play g5 and play
with all these pawn moves
but you seem to play them boldly was
this preparation for you beforehand um i
i had looked at it briefly i mean it was
the position has it's so complicated and
there's many options for both sides that
it's difficult to
um to check everything
um but i i thought that this position
was at least playable
should have been checked a bit more
because
it's very difficult to play over the
board i have to say his rookie one move
was very good um i think i'm not sure if
he found it over the board or if he had
known something before the game
um
but this move i knew was was very
dangerous but um
i i think that
that yeah after this i didn't respond
accurately a4 wasn't the best
i mean maybe it's playable but i think
that g4 and e5 is a more accurate way
the move or rook e8 we were talking
about maintaining the tension we said
rookie 8 looked like a strong move the
engines thought you were fine in this
position but just chatting with you
before we came on the air you felt like
that wasn't quite comfortable for you
either yeah it looked a bit loose um and
yeah he could take on d5 or he could
play queen f2 first um and my king is
always very shaky maybe a computer will
defend it but
over the board it seemed too risky how
do you handle a tough start round one of
a tournament like this one a lot of a
lot of good memories for you from last
year now you've lost the first round how
do you handle the disappointment
i'll try to come back quickly if i can
um i don't think that
um
that if you start badly at the end of
the tournament or if you start well it
means you're going to
to perform well the rest of the event um
in in norway
um
my
one of my uh
one of the most recent tournaments i
played the first leg of the grand chess
tour i i started pretty well i drew
against mishi i beat magnus in the
second round and the event didn't go
well very well for me after that
um and then in the next event at
dortmund i
i lost in the second round and then i
won five games in a row and and won the
tournament so
uh i wouldn't say that it's uh i mean it
it's not pleasant to start with a loss
but it isn't
the end of the tournament by any means
wise words well thanks so much for
joining us admirably after such a tough
game and we wish you the best in the
rest of the tournament
grand master fabiano caruana after a
tough loss to start off but a lot of
rounds to play here in
uh the sink field cup 2015. guys
a lot of rounds to play we just started
round one that's right he doesn't have a
lot of room he can uh he can still uh
recapture the cops right
but um whoa a lot of heart attacks will
be had at the excitement level of chess
i mean we could actually have all
decisive games today so um i was just
looking at the game uh while they were
having the conversation on ishgary
um grishok right so after this in
between move that you suggested c3 um
kind of intriguing obviously if white
were to capture then that would
alleviate black of all of his problems
as queen
is now out of uh
capture
check king h2 c3
uh trying to give his queen a square so
that after rook takes c3 the queen will
go back to b4
defending the rook and at the moment
we're in exchange up right
and what's the difference the other one
was different because we
were able to take on b6
and then we just ended up a clear pawn
with uh yes it's a party time exactly so
um yeah we'll have to take a look at
this in just a minute but right now
we've got the man of the
champion the cup holder he's with
grandmaster maurice ashley
we are with the winner first winner of
sing field cup lavon aronian lavon
yesterday at the press conference i
remarked on how poorly a year had gone
and you said america land of opportunity
time to turn things around it looks like
you took advantage of that opportunity
today in winning your game uh yeah i
think it worked out pretty well so
uh i mean my worst during press
conference i i didn't
regret them i didn't get to regret them
now this game was crazy i mean this was
one of the first games we started paying
attention to along with the game that
magnus was playing in his in that
contest but this game was wild were you
surprised by his demonstrations with
with
f6 g5 and e5 and f5 and all those pawns
just coming up the board
it was interesting because i know this
line a bit i mean i've i kind of
analyzed a long time ago and i was
feeling that it's interesting to play
and
i i felt that this is the only way for
black to proceed otherwise i mean if he
allows me to play f4
which i'm threatening after knight d2
then
it's practically hopeless because he's
just sitting there waiting for me to do
anything i mean so of course this this
is a very uh normal uh to play for black
but i was a bit surprised with f5 i have
to
say honestly i was thinking he would go
edie and here i prepared rook c2 c1
which i felt is very very meaning
pre-game preparation
you're thinking of yeah yeah i was
thinking of uh rook c2 c1 i thought
that's that's a very subtle move and
might be a good move because i'm
threatening to play e5
so
i felt the the position is kind of
balanced but i i kind of like when my
opponent has a wicked king
makes it a lot easier now there was one
position uh we did talk about rookie
eight but there was one position where
you were playing these moves uh you
sacrificed the rook
around let's see if we can get to the
position here on the board right here
when he played knight to d4 now what
were you thinking when you saw this line
cause you did go into a bit of a thing
and knight you saw knight d4 and queen
h5 was possible did you work everything
out say this is just over if he goes
after your rook yeah i saw rook f1 queen
f6 and here i saw millions of wins so
it's good enough for me and uh 94 i was
kind of uh thinking he would play knight
d6 but it's just too hopeless indeed in
this position you played the move queen
h5 and then he took your rook you took
and after bishop f5 this beautiful move
rook f1 i'm assuming you saw the
variation with rook g6 rf7 and and
that's going to be all she wrote in
those lines were you smiling when that
was happening on the board yeah cause
it's kind of beautiful so you don't get
a chance to play a nice move like queen
h6 and
he cannot do anything yes absolutely now
we were arguing okay
and and jen you know she has a soft spot
so she was arguing on your side we're
saying would this go down in the annals
of chess history a beautiful attacking
game when in this position you play
queen f6 and it was possible to play
rook takes f5 right now and you instead
opted for the move knight to e6 and then
you said to me you saw this and and what
was your remark
yeah it's kind of a lazy choice 96 but
it also you know
i think capoblanca was who said
if you have a choice between winning
opponents queen for free and giving him
a mate just take the queen
because my
you might not find a mate
and i saw that i'm just taking
everything so i i didn't think i should
bother to
i mean think
uh at that moment for too long
okay well lazy chess i i'm not going to
tell my students about lazy chess by the
way although i do have a student robert
guzman who used to say even when he had
made on the board and he's about to take
your queen he said no no i'll let you
get out of the mate just so i can take
your claim i don't think you would agree
with that one but uh but certainly it's
too much realistic even for me
you have a great start now first first
round is over what are your thoughts
about the rest of the tournament
well i'm excited because i won in the
first round uh
against a strong opponent so
i'll uh
try to win some more so that's the plan
now not to stop uh
i mean to continue uh playing well
because i think today i i played well
well we hope to see more of those games
congratulations thank you very much best
of luck in the rest of the singapore cup
lavon aronian welcome back to america
the land of opportunity he certainly
took advantage in this game guys i can't
let you go without asking a question to
lavon lavonne was there any moment in
the game
that you were tempted to use the
confessional
um
i actually forgot about it because i was
so excited attacking my opponent
otherwise i sure would use it
it brings up
another conversation you know we're
talking all the time down here in the
studio but another conversation was
would you use the confessional when
you're clearly winning when the game is
just over uh would you run in there to
just say yay i'm winning
would that be your use of the
confessional just to brag i don't think
so
i mean the opponents are anyway
i mean the viewers anyway know that
you're winning
so i i think it's better to use it when
the position is unclear and you have
something interesting to share with the
public great that gives us a point
against jennifer you know we go for
brownie points down here
thank you so much thank you so much for
joining us uh guys back to you thank you
uh well the score's one one but i gotta
say i'd love to see lavonne in in there
trash talking because his trash is
legendary but i guess in classical chess
it doesn't have the exact same effect as
it does in bug house well the thing is i
think that lavon would be a great
confessional uh speaker whether he had a
terrible position so he could tell you
all about what has gone wrong and how he
messed up and he misanalyzed this as
well as when he's completely winning and
he can explain to you how everything is
beautiful is the way it works exactly
it's very nice i don't know if you want
to be known as a great confessional
speaker that's true i don't think so
either we're going to take a quick break
and we'll be back with the very exciting
acting here at the syncfield club as we
go to the time control all right
good
welcome back to the 2015 sink field cup
you'll see the one empty table of our
one fallen king fabiano caruana last
year's champion
started the tournament with a loss but
even bigger news might be on top of this
round as our world champion
the main king of the world in chess is
he going down as well with the white
pieces well chess fans we've got an
amazing start to this great event magnus
carlson yes is in serious trouble
back here at this position that i have
on my demo board
we thought that magnus had somehow
managed to conjure up
some compensation for the peace
sacrifice he had made earlier we had
anticipated that a knight takes f8 and a
bishop h6 would get him some material
back instead he came up with this really
poor choice e4 e5
magnus had in mind that he's going to
get a knight f6 check or perhaps the
knight takes f8 in the position but he
missed a very nice maneuver by vessel
and vessel and found queen c6 setting up
a checkmate in one threat against the g2
pawn magnus had to parry that threat
with the move f2 f3 and then this fine
defensive resource queen g6 was played
and met this tried knight f6 check to
try to confuse the issue it didn't
confuse it one single bit
king d8 by the way these moves were
blitzed out so again
and not not feeling intimidated in the
slightest and i guess the the striking
thing there was he he thought the top
level would at some point be compelled
to sacrifice the rook for the knight on
h7 but all of a sudden with this queen
c6 g6 maneuver he was just keeping the
rock exactly and just one trick that
not to allow you couldn't take the
knight and walk yourself into a discover
check because then after the king
the king moves you take the rook there's
no more checkmate threat on g2 if you
try to take the queen well thank you
very much i've uh promoted myself uh to
a queen and it's white who would win
but vessel and seeing through that very
easily uh just slid his king over to d8
and now
there's there's the checkmate threat on
g2 that had to be addressed that
actually forced magnus to trade the
queens and now he although he has two
pawns i believe two pawns for
a piece it's not even close to being
sufficient compensation and topolof
really is uh in the driver's seat in
this one and should win the game and
should win the game unless i forget he
is the grand chester champion well
leader leader yes sorry the champion of
the norway chess 2015 which was the
first event and he got 13 grand tour
points for this so i'm beating the world
champion in the second game you know
wrestling's really looking at
well that's exactly the point as we
started our show i mean uh magnus
carlson was winning that game in norway
that he lost on time and it was a huge
swing of one whole point vessel and
topolof leveraged that victory uh to
victory in the tournament whereas
magnus's fortunes went just the other
way and he had the worst uh tournament
of his professional chess career in the
last 10 years that's right and he wants
to stop the bleeding here in in st louis
but unfortunately he's starting with a
more of the same and you know the last
thing we want is from is for uh magnus
to associate the grand chess tour with
poor forum because there's another event
after this one exactly right so uh he's
gotta he's gotta have to figure out
what's up in this game and i think
what's interesting in this round one is
we're gonna see lots of blood spilled
not just in these two marquee games but
also it looks like all across fury is
crushing and um i know i don't know
about gary actually i'm sorry i meant to
say um
maxine bashir like rob looks like he's
crushing the last time we checked and i
think it's gotten even better it's an
exchange so a lot of blood going on just
to address this position that we have on
our board by the way it seems to me that
vessel and has several approaches he
might take the first one is bishop b7
just to establish this bishop on the
diagonal hopefully after a move like
knight takes c5 you've set up for bishop
takes f3
with material advantage as well as the
initiative
another approach that vessel may take is
he's recognizing that this pawn on c5 c5
is on pre he might just go back with
move knight d7 bringing his knight back
to both attack and defense
uh again
lots of nice choices here and it all
looks very favorable for former world
champion vessel and topolof continuing
our search i thought that uh vishy had
placed himself into some troubles uh as
we see
all four rooks
are
loaded up so to speak on the c file in
uh uh world champion uh four not five
time world champion vishy anand in a
little bit of trouble i didn't see
exactly how to break down the move
bishop d6 but i thought that uh you
thought the bishop 85 was a threat here
well i
i thought that it's just a it looks like
a very nice position for white but maybe
it's just one of those positions it only
looks good it's one of those things
even a threat here though weirdly um
can't you just like
take and then be three-handed yeah
exactly
you see this and you're like oh [ __ ] of
85 wins wait a second no right and
there's even this one move bishop a3
kind of annoyingly you know forcing
white off of the uh c file so maybe that
was only uh it only looked good not
necessarily was uh
as good as it looked going back to the
gary game like this kind of
for for alexander grishik by the way
with 12 moves to make is that right yeah
but look at that 25 minutes so anish has
spent a lot of time too so rook me one
shaq
uh key move key swish and soup move and
now he's got a pawn for the exchange
rook a1 and bishop
but rook f okay rook f1
that rook's kind of trapped
along the back ring you don't see that
every day rook f1 knight v2 so so i'm
assuming that uh the offer of the
exchange allowing mcqueen to kind of
drop in and perhaps cause some havoc
because we might be threatening
kind of the knight e4 type move or like
a knight d3 move and you're saying hey
look your rook is just ending up trapped
on the first rank so alexander grishok
in trouble on the board and on the clock
and what i was trying to say was if
white just took on f1 after queen f1 we
would be maybe we maybe would be trying
to
and trying to see what the counter play
would be there but well he's from what
from black's point of view he's got his
queen in the game and maybe
he could sniff around for some yeah
maybe like visit
at least and then you take on a4 and f2
is hanging so that queen on d3 might end
up being a queen on c2 rather might end
up being a little overworked bishop e2
perhaps trying to get into f3 so that's
why he didn't take that rook just way
more trouble than it's worth um
meanwhile uh
we've got maurice ashley with some more
thoughts on this game
not just on this game jen but all the
games because now we're approaching time
pressure and everyone just about except
geary seems to be feeling the heat just
a bit which means we're going to
probably see some imprecisions in the
next few moves first this position gary
has 23 minutes lots of time on the clock
he has different moves he can play to
play the move d5 in this position the
engine is also pointing out this
sacrifice rook takes a six sacrificing
another exchange and after queen takes
now knight b to c4 and this you don't
see every day a black rook trapped on
the back rank inside the position an
amazing sequence black would have to go
and take on f2 with his rook and just
give away his rook in this position
white would have two pieces for the rook
and great chances with this d pawn the
two bishops to real home the point
certainly a position he'll be looking at
but again with the time pressure issue
let's take a look at the game with anand
and and nakamura nakamura having played
35 f4 in this position here anan had
really fixed his game and he had this
subtlety bishop to a3 first chasing the
rook off of the c1 square but instead of
doing that this this causing some
discoordination between these two pieces
instead he very quickly just played the
defensive move bishop d6 why is that
he's only got nine minutes on the clock
to make the rest of his moves six moves
not so bad but this is like i said the
imprecisions those little tiny errors
start to creep in if you got plenty of
time in the clock you find those moves
but you start to play quickly and you
miss them so that's a challenge there as
well this position another one wesley so
down in exchange he's got a pawn for it
but his position is definitely bad but
look at the clocks both sides under 15
minutes 11 minutes the 13 minutes on the
clock they've got to make 12 moves now
as far as black's concern he's up a big
exchange for a pawn he's looking to make
something happen but still
maybe something might creep in there we
feel the pressure of that game and the
final game of course is the one between
magnus carlson our world champion and
vasily topolov
22 moves only played in that game both
sides also at 13 minutes and 11 minutes
18 moves to go
can magnus hope against hope will he
hope against hope that topalov will make
some kind of error can he do anything to
make sure that he makes it a little bit
messy and somehow topolov lets him back
in the game he has not played this game
well at all he went from bad position to
suddenly back in the game maybe even
advantage to now just a very bad looks
like losing position and he's thinking
it through
can time be on his side how will they
manage time pressure as we go into the
next
20 minutes or so as these players feel
the heat in round one of this 2015 sink
field cup
wow and i can't tell you how important
as we saw in norway
this first round between these two
players
was i mean vessel and went on to have a
fantastic tournament to become the grand
chester
leader
and
magnus came fully fully motivated for
this game you know that uh jen you're a
world champion you want to re-establish
the the order of things
and
to
be in trouble against the same opponent
who beat you in norway that was not
a part of magnus's preparation
let's put it that way so big big trouble
for the world champion in this game
that's right and what were the odds that
he would play drapala with the same
color in the first round we were
mentioning it was something like one out
of 350 right well yeah i think
something like being like maybe 81 to 81
to one i mean
with the exact same colors yes yeah so
it's kind of a
an interesting uh
but for for the result the result would
be the same twice too that's kind of
yeah that definitely has to be hundreds
to one right
but of course the two the two different
the two different games were extremely
different the other one um magnus was
actually winning in the final position
but forgot about the time control
exactly whereas if uh
polo does end up
winning this game and showing um some
nice technique it'll be uh
great opening idea grand chester may be
decided uh within uh two tournaments
okay so from black's point of view he's
super super happy he's a piece ahead
um
everything's going his way but on the
other hand how do you reel home the
point so first things first
there are some problems in black's camp
okay his king is not ideal this bishop
on f8 is not ideal and there is a
weakness a little
patch key out here with this last move
h2h4
by um
magnus what he is hoping to be able to
do is to put his bishop on g5 which
would neutralize the pressure of the
rook on along the g file and then slide
his rook over to the c1 square to try to
attack this pawn on c5 so there are some
concrete problems that vessel has to
solve
i
would probably start with the move
knight d7 okay first of all it attacks
the pawn at par me it defends the pawn
on c5 while attacking the pawn on e5 if
you could get a knight takes e5 and
knight takes f3 well that's all she
wrote
uh
if
magnus was obliged to put his bishop on
f4 then i would want to put this bishop
on g7 and in case of for example a move
like rook d1 i'd want to slide my king
back over here where i feel it's nice
and safe in the middle of the board
because the queens are off very
importantly off the table so this i
think is the way for vessel and to go
there are there are other approaches
just to mention one other i might add is
that you won't want to play move for
example like e6 and stick this bishop in
the middle of the board and say i'm
i'm boss in the middle of the board
there with bishop d5 but i i like
keeping the pawn on e7 and going through
what i said knight d7 bishop f4 bishop
g7 king e8
still a lot to play for and time
may be a key factor eight minutes
for
magnus and 12 minutes for vessel and now
let's take a look at uh
um i i want to take a look at mbl who
looks like he's uh
really cruising in this position he was
the exchange up yep against wesley so
with the black pieces let's go back
maurice had left us around these parts
takes takes
boy
following the rule went ahead and
material trade
trade majors
that was what best uh what nbl had tried
and queen d6
looking just
to try to trick
his opponent
by attacking the maurice
what's the trick what do you mean
well he wants to go rook d3 i beg your
pardon he wants to go rook d3
and uh try to grab that rook maurice you
got some thoughts about what's going on
in these games
just very quickly a big development in
the game between nakamura and anand if
you take a look at this position right
here we saw that bishop a3 idea was
possible let's just go back one second
to this position bishop a3 was the main
move but he played bishop d6 that
prompted f4 from nakamura and now the
move f5 chasing the bishop back and here
the engine thinks rook to b8 instead the
move knight to b8
based on a miscalculation maybe not sure
rook takes c7 rook takes rook takes
bishop takes and now thanks for the pawn
on g5 this has not been played as yet
it's still moved 39 but here he could
take on g5 takes bishop takes and bishop
a4 that would be move 40. but at the end
of it it looks like black has gotten his
pawn back and suddenly the move knight
c5 appears on the board and two guys are
being hit in the position but maybe anan
is estimating that even if he gives you
the a pawn in some variation maybe say
bishop to d7 will he be okay in this
position will he survive the two bishops
but three pawns on the same side looking
like a good chance for anan so it looks
as if he's jumped into that variation
hoping that he'll get a draw out of that
line despite being upon down
wow
well i certainly wouldn't have gone for
this lineup at all i'm sure
uh vishy has missed
something in his calculations to prompt
him to play knight b8 i didn't think his
position was that bad
that he suddenly sees the defensive
uh as he has done and it looks like uh
we might envy let's let's take a look at
the uh mbl gary game again
um you mean uh what what's this i'm
sorry yeah oh no sorry yuri grushak
first
sorry um all the games look like her
yeah i think they're so close to
potential finales here so it got it got
wild uh
getting trapped it wasn't worth his
trouble to take on f1 instead he wants
to take it just for free right well
knight knight b2 sets up uh blocking
this diagonal with this move knight b2
to c4
um
sasha's dropped back queen b7
rook takes
and this was the line that maurice is
pointing out that you could get
you just grab this rook for free uh back
here it's trapped
so
knight takes e4 whoa
knight takes e4
bishop takes e4 again
black has not solved
how he's going to
how is black going to solve his his
problem with his rook he played rook b8
well i think onish is well on his way to
victory now he has played bishop takes
h7 check king h8 and
this looks
like well d7 is hanging as well right
yeah well there's knight d7 in the
position there's queens and we have some
more moves oh we have i beg your pardon
i'm not up to date yeah so after rook b8
between 7 king f8 we have instead of 97
which looks good we had just queen e2 i
was about to say i like queenie too very
much because after rook c1 i can set up
a mating threat with queen f3 i'm a
threatening mate over here
and and it's over right d7 so this is a
decisive game of the syncfield cup also
the second game and honest theory off to
a beautiful start here in st louis i
just love these people who think that
chess has played out
well and i think
oh and look at this move by maxine
vasyar legrobins was he so i think so's
gonna go down in in just a minute too so
you were mentioning um that uh queen d6
perhaps created some counter play but
guess what it also created more counter
play for black rook c8 and now the idea
of rook takes c1 is in the position
um queen takes e3 check and uh this just
yikes this just looks like everything is
hanging right here yikes that looks like
a tremendous move i messed up over here
i mean the bishop can't come to d2
because d1 is hanging i can't come to b2
it's basically trapped um so
i think uh maurice is an all decisive
game perhaps this round wow maurice is
he wrapping up victory
i just wanted to point out the finish of
the other game just quickly after queen
e2 he did play rook c1 and the key move
he played was queen to h5 that was the
body blow that just ended it the mate
threat here if you play g6 then he just
sacrifices thank you very much you're
not going to survive this one if you
take this well first of all queen h8
mate is on tap f7 is hanging if you take
this one oh thank you we still got mate
going it's just over this position was
busted which is why he resigned after
queen h5 a horrible start for grizzchuk
what's the deal with this guy's time
pressure addiction he just keeps getting
more and more tough situations and just
shedding rating points as he's tumbled
out of the top 10 and go fading fast if
he doesn't correct this no way in the
world he stays at the top of world chess
he's got to fix this problem because
playing against these top players
they're showing him no way in the world
we're going to let you get away with
such a big weakness
well well put i i know i work with
victor korchnoy for well over a year and
a half and nothing i could say or do
could cure
cure him of his time trouble addiction
something he suffered through his entire
life let's see what has happened on
board number one again major major
match up
magnus carlson had just played the move
h4 when we left it
rook c8 okay
rook c8 was thessalon's choice i thought
he was going to do something else
h5 also a little bit of a surprise for
me i thought
that magnus's intention was to put his
bishop on
g5 h5
drove the rook backwards bishop d2 uh be
careful heads up there is a bishop a5
a sneak attack from the side
knight c4 bishop c3 i know uh topolov
grabs the chance to blockade that pawn
well
oh blockade the h-pawn i beg your pardon
yes even more so than blockading the
h-pawn vessel is looking at knight
e3
to
launch uh a decisive attack on white's
king
and
we we have some moves we have work do
you want jack and king
sorry my mouth seems to have
uh let me just refresh my board for a
moment i beg your pardon
okay so we do have uh rook d1 king e8
rook d3 and so we're up to date with the
current position
magnus has just defended his e3 square
and vessel don't you get the sense that
we're looking in a game where one player
is up a piece
i do i mean i
really do it's like a technical analysis
that's what it's coming down to yeah i
mean what's the fastest way what's the
way to leave the most counter play but
is the result in doubt i mean stranger
things have happened but
in the large majority of cases this game
is just going to go in the direction of
the players up a piece i mean these are
2800 players agreed uh topolof is a
big big favor to win this game
and uh
maurice you have
something to share about the hikaru
nakamura vishi anand position
yes the players there may time control
but nakamura looks like he's doing well
although maybe the game's not quite over
yet but he's got to be somewhat content
with his position he can't lose he
played knight c5 here instead of taking
on g5 he played knight c5 first and
after bishop to d6 shedding this pawn
now bishop takes on a4 was played and
nakamura said hey thanks a lot i'll take
this guy off the board for you and after
the bishop dropped back and now bishop
to c3 and this position may not have
been the perfect moose with nakamura
remember again the time pressure was a
factor but it looks as though he's just
up a solid pawn and remember before we
didn't have this nice juicy pass pawn
well h4h58687
better watch out for that because that
could come easily and black with hoping
that maybe this pawn might be a
distraction this looks like a very nice
position position for nakamura he'll be
looking to try to win this game and join
all the bloodbath that's happening here
in the first round of the sink field cup
indeed five we're gonna get five out of
the decisive games here well i i always
thought you know if you got one or two
wins out of the five games that's been a
combative round i mean you can't imagine
you know five decisive games and when
you've got the top 10 players in the
world all battling with each other guys
hey is that girl in the front row
carrying one of your books she's like
touching it for dear life well like i
feel like it might be chest stools yeah
yeah it looks like it might be right the
red fawn on the back yeah we'll just go
with that well i sure hope it doesn't
ruin our games
oh my
okay but i will
my feeling uh in that game between
hakara this ending
uh speaking as a technical player for
just a quick moment i think this is just
stone cold winning
for
hikaru i don't think he's going to have
any trouble whatsoever reeling on the
whole point here i can just imagine just
as maurice was saying you give white a
move like e3 king f2 and then he just
starts trundling as h pawn up the board
that's over so
uh
more likely who's more likely to save
carlson or anon
i mean i know it's a close one because
it looks like
we're pretty confident of the results of
both games exactly but if you had to
pick one player who's going to say i've
heard you're back
maybe magnus is this something about the
star power of playing against the
current world champion that somehow
world champions
they're good and they get lucky
hypnotized yeah you can make their
opponent do something crazy something
happens when you're playing against
i'm gonna go with the other the other
way and zaynon's more likely to save but
you know what um we're probably both
gonna lose this bet yeah exactly we do
have a move and by the way we also are
getting set up for our next guest yes we
got our our next
our next winner today we've got oh and
and wait uh i already lose the bet that
was fast it looks like uh
hikaru nakamura has become our third
winner of the day well like i said i
thought it was just over i just i didn't
expect vichy to resign
i did it i did expect hikaru to win but
i think i thought he would have to
play say it doesn't move was a good
technique but fishy so
the carnage continues here at the sink
field cup and we do have
our second special guest we've got anish
fury about his victory today he's with
maurice ashley
thanks jen with grand master anish giri
from holland
newly married and new into america first
tournament here and a win must be very
nice to start off the tournament in such
a way yeah i have a little bit of a deja
vu because
in my
first
tournament of the series where i played
in norway i also took the first number
and i also had to play grishok and i
also beat him basically out of the
opening so i had a feeling of deja vu
today and let's hope i'll continue
playing as well
that's a very good point and none of us
spotted that pattern guys we have to
kick ourselves over there because nobody
cares about my games
i understand that
we do we do care we do we do and and
also time pressure what is going on with
grisha getting in this kind of time
pressure well i think the time pressure
was is always always his trademark uh
but uh
probably with um
when he's in bad shape it looks
it looks really painful i guess if you
are his supporter but
when he's in a good shape you know
it all doesn't matter he has yesterday
he has his 30 seconds and
he's making his moves anyway do you
think the fact that he doesn't have an
increment is also affecting his play as
well as he manages the time pressure
well
obviously having increment is much
better for a player like him but in
today's game i think
his position was really really bad so
it was not only the time but mostly the
position that really
you know cost
costing the point
what do you think about this crazy round
uh first of all you've got fabiano going
down and just a vicious attack the way
he fell apart that was a beautiful game
on the part of eronion yeah i must say
that i all the games they started so
excitingly with the two games
starting with g5 by black i thought i
might even
repeat moves in my game because you know
there was enough excitement for people
anyway but but okay finally i
i played my own game but of course the
fabiano's
opening preparation was
very very concrete
and i know this uh disorientation and
clearly white has to black has to know
exactly what he's doing because he's
weakening himself all over the place he
has a bad bishop he has a weak king
but okay he he has his own trumps and he
has to be really precise and probably
fabiano was unable to recall
the details and uh yeah after that when
i saw that one sacrificing the rook
um actually
i actually wasn't sure if fabian had to
had to lose to take the rook but
but yeah i guess white had a devastating
attack anyway had a big attack and then
also nakamura beating anand another
interesting game that looked like it was
just going to be a draw yeah that was a
very different game i think they played
a very quiet variation and um
yeah well not very often if black makes
two precise moves the game is over and
uh nobody pays attention to the game
ever again but uh
you know hikaru probably had some
you know some move order which was
slightly forgotten maybe and uh and we
made few inaccuracies and once you get a
horrible position uh it's a lot of
suffering in catalan and uh
hikaru of course uh
is very good at you know nursing a small
plus well if you'll be kind enough
before i let you go so let's get that
board with not with uh carlson and
topolov if we might just get a quick
opinion about the position from anish
geary if we could see the the picture on
the board first of all the way the way
he played this game the world champion
it just did not look impressive now
they're both in time pressure if we
could just see the the the two
the angle the 2d board so we can take a
look at it this angle is not doing as
much justice this one here he's down a
piece uh for
looks like two pawns looks like black is
no he wasn't technically technically
winning but i i was surprised in opening
because i think my wife is aware of the
move g5 in the night of and i don't know
why magnus isn't
of course you know once you you have to
calculate uh this complicated position
by yourself it's quite difficult
and what he did looked very saying your
wife's not as good as magnus
noel she's of course
almost as good as a player but she's not
in a famous theoretician so that's what
i'm the point i'm trying to make
uh but um clean that up later don't get
into any trouble right now
she knows me she knows me we are you are
used to this kind of uh corals but
yeah to be honest what he did was very
very inspired he sacrificed a full piece
but i think he overestimated his
initiative somewhat because after this
move d4 it looks like white has all all
sorts of threats but suddenly you just
make a logical retreat and it turns out
that okay you can win a second pawn but
two pawns for peace is not enough
all right we will join this game shortly
we'll let you go and uh clean that up
with your wife or yeah whatever you guys
do to deal with quarrels yeah but thank
you so much anish welcome to the united
states and to st louis and
congratulations on a fine start thank
you anish geary always a gentleman a
great young player one of the top 10 in
the world and winning in fine style to
start his time here at the sink field
cup guys wow and who would have thought
that i mean she might actually only be
tied for fifth after this game
that's a nice way of putting it um well
things are definitely heating up look at
the time trouble what is the what are
the exact clock times
36 seconds
for the world championship we just saw
him uh blast out a move there i think
that was knight f2
33 seconds left for the world champion
and two minutes left for zapalov of
course the position is still
looking absolutely crushing i mean look
at these tactics on f3 and f2 but
for the moment he looks like he's
holding on bishop f2 we can play king
takes f2
but what about just
there's got to be something here right
well it's just taking on f3 right at
some point oh my gosh
taking on it well not immediately but
maybe we can take on e5 and f3 and then
there's a little skewer like a bishop e5
f3
right you want to do something like well
it would be great if there wasn't that
pawn on b2 right you could just take a
bit and pick up this bishop but uh so
bishop but i was thinking bishop b5
first and then bishop f3 perhaps
um because then if bishop yeah that
looks pretty crushing did he play it
he did play it bishop takes c5 bishop
takes c5 bishop takes f3
very nice skewering the rooks magnus
left to 19 seconds and he played knight
g4 but now he's down
knight g4 are you sure oh no no no no he
didn't take on e5 of course okay
sorry
[ __ ] of e5 he's just playing 94. okay
so whoa i thought what
bishop e5 winning up clipping upon and
now we've got the moves are just are
blasting out so let's just try to catch
up with them so what happened after
knight g4 bishop takes c3 i assume um
i'm trying to catch up with the board
here yeah bishop c3 bc3 king f8 and king
f2
um that's that brings us to move 35.
and magnus has but a single pawn for a
piece well this is totally hopeless of
course
but they've got like like five seconds
in the clock each actually 54 to 12.
really 54 to 12.
so this is just i'm assuming magnus is
the one with the 12. yes
15 seconds actually um 95. hold on let
me just refresh my box
h8 95 also occurred
so you've got you've got the board
refreshed okay yeah so it went rook h8
give me the pawn 95 95 rookie five and
vessel and topple off the bishop ahead
to play
um bishop b8
bishop and g4 bishop e8 and we are
they're playing so fast we're just about
to make time only seven seconds left
guys seven seconds on magnus's clock
wow to seventeen seconds sixty six
counting down
f6 rookie six and just one more move for
each player to make bishop b5 i assume
by vessel yeah bishop b5 that's very
nice just concretely defending the pawn
and preparing king f7 and rookie one
works c7 and we've made time to draw and
of course
black is is just um up a piece yeah so
but that wow that was a flurry of
activity there huh wow well the boats
they probably have really had melt and
had used their clock and they milked it
for a long time
you don't see that with increment i mean
that's just like such a such a shocking
sight not something you see these days
but we have
vishyanan with maurice ashley to talk
about today's game all right
with the five-time
world champion vishwanathan on on after
a difficult game today
vishy today's game it just looked kind
of tepid uh not so interesting and it
looked like you were completely fine and
then all of a sudden something happened
what happened in the game well i just
blundered with f5 i just forgot that the
bishop could go to d3 for some reason i
kept putting it on the long diagonal and
that was it i mean it was a game of one
move
incredible why do you think that
happened was it the time pressure it
looks like time pressure was happening
on a lot of boards did that affect you
perhaps i mean i was running down on
time and i wanted to
play something precise and i blundered
instead but
it seems like it was a completely crazy
day today normally you know right out
the gate to see what it looks like it's
going to be five decisive games in the
first round
what's in the water
i don't know i can only speak for myself
but i just had a very bad day so
so
you've had bad days before it's not the
first time in your life how do you come
back from a game like this from round
one and play the rest of the games well
well you
nothing much to be done you just have to
take it you go back and play the next
game and that's it so do you forget is
it something you forget easily or or
does it linger i don't think this game
i'll forget easily but well there's
nothing much to be done
all right well we are very thrilled to
have you here in st louis we look
forward to seeing you ride the ship and
good luck in the rest of your games okay
thank you
world champion former world champion
with jonathan anand joining us after a
tough start we'll look to see how he
does it bounces back
in the future rounds nice by the way we
also have a result jan in the wesley so
game we i don't think we mentioned it we
got uh captured by the time travel but
we do in fact have four
decisive results and it looks like from
the
uh magnus game that's going to be five
i mean how does it how does this happen
in singapore cup that somehow we have
these extraordinarily combative games
and
the players are just bringing it that's
right and well we've got one player who
certainly brought it today
wow
wow
what a start all very different wins
right lavon
crushing attack and we've got under the
the blunder
by vichy as he said that's right and
then uh chaplain's game was quite
interesting right being nuanced okay so
i mean essentially what happened there
was
g5 was a very upsetting move right and
then
magnus found some play
sacrificed the piece had the initiative
had full compensation at one point
and then
pitched it all right back with a single
bad move e4 e5
and then thereafter it looked like
topolof played really really well
to secure the position he currently has
which is winning of course
and we have hikaru nakamura currently
number two in the world after that
victory wow
congratulations
grand master and u.s champion hikaru
nakamura after defeating vishwanathan
anand first of all congratulations on
your victory thanks now were you
surprised the position you were milking
you were milking it was a little
something then it looked like it might
have been equal and all of a sudden he
plays this move and you're winning were
you surprised by this happening in the
game
yeah i mean uh okay this is very strong
player he tends to be pretty well
prepared so i knew it was going to be a
difficult struggle um
and i think the way you you beat him i
mean i i i don't want to you know
make fun of him but but in a way the way
that you beat someone like vichy because
he's a bit older is to get these sorts
of positions where you have very slight
edges and just keep pressing because he
is 45 years old so um
that's that's what i was aiming for was
to get a small small maybe a small
advantage and just play it play chess
really as long as i could and
yeah i got a bit lucky that vichy played
f5 um he had some better moves in the
position but you know i'll i'll take it
certainly
what do you think give us perspective
we're here at the sinkhole cup it's the
grand chess tour we're seeing five
victories magnus carlson just losing as
well
what's going on
um i don't know i think everyone just
wants to play exciting chess uh
and in norway chess i believe there were
four decisive games as well in the first
round so um
sometimes people just want to play
interesting chess and when that happens
there tend to be a lot of decisive games
because you reach positions that are
very imbalanced where both sides have
chances and at this level everyone's so
strong that um
i mean
anything can happen once you're out of
the opening
big point i mean black won two games
today so it wasn't just white
railroading black two it's going to be
three i think it's it three i think it's
wow it's even three incredible uh so or
no it's two ceramics yeah i thought it
was vashi lagrav and topalov right so
those are the two wins so uh
when when when this happens it seems
like winning the first round does almost
doesn't matter because it's almost i
mean of course it's important but it's
almost like a push because you got four
guys who are tied for first with you
yeah well i mean even even if i was the
only one to win today i wouldn't really
make very much out of it because it's a
very long tournament and everyone's so
strong that anything anything can happen
really
we'd have to get an opinion on the game
with the magnus i mean he lost it to
paula of under weird circumstances in
the first
in norway but now the way he lost today
was just bizarre
can you make anything of of him losing
in first round against zapalov here at
the stingfield car um i mean
it's i think topalov's playing playing
very well at the moment so um
it's certainly surprising to see magnus
play this way after all he's
been so consistent for the past five to
six years that it's surprising but that
being said everyone's so strong and on
any given day i mean as you see anything
can happen early well thanks so much for
joining us and sharing those thoughts
and good luck in the rest of your games
thanks maurice u.s champ and currently
well now number three in the world you
know things flip on a dime when you're
at those verified air position
situations but certainly a good victory
for the u.s champion hikaru nakamura
guys he's wearing the color of the round
isn't he red
what a way to start our 2015 sing phil
cup jeff yeah that's right just i'm
i'm taking it back
yeah i absolutely love this round so
much fun watching it um
so clearly lavon oronion um just game of
the day
i don't have to give him that
best game of the day who do you think's
in second place
uh because like the other games were
like were hard were messier right a lot
of a lot of people happen in time
pressure
vessel
game was messy but in a certain
sense he played very well i mean okay
the opening was bizarre and little
subtle differences here and there but
when you really came down to it he
played a lot of really good work even
with a minute left on the clock he found
the 65 bishop f3 did you just put it
away and get ready for tomorrow on issue
is very dominating let's put that one in
perspective that was a dominating clear
win and we better start paying attention
to the game
exactly and he was undefeated in norway
that's right and another victory today
we had was maxine bashir lagrave he beat
our wild card wesley so and he's going
to talk about that game with maurice
ashley
we're with france's number one player
maxine vashila grav who is off to a
great start here at the sink field cup
maxim when we were looking at the
position we were thinking i was thinking
to myself how am i going to explain to
my students that you know you shouldn't
move the same piece twice in the opening
he played knight f3 g5 e4 they put his
queen on a4 and b5 and then he played
his knight from c3 to a4 and it's like
how do you explain that position were
you surprised by the way he was playing
uh just going after your c-pawn
well in general going after
a pawn
is a good idea if you
manage to to keep a solid position in
fact i had looked at this line but it
was a long time ago and i couldn't
remember but then it it means that i
looked at this
just giving the pawn opening the a file
and
getting a lot of contemporaries with all
my pieces and it looks very fine for me
were you happy when you saw that
position on the board because after you
played e5 it just looked like black has
full compensation
yeah i mean definitely i thought i had
full compensation
and then another moment when i was happy
with when i found
this bishop f5 forcing some
conversations
then was less like the exchange i think
it was the right decision
and then i was not sure i played in the
most precise way but
still i kept some advantage maybe i
could have defended better at some point
i don't know but
it was quite convincing i thought
at one moment you went into the
confessional booth why did you choose
right at that time to go in
well i mean i
at first it was really messy and then
when
it was exactly when i played bishop f5
and i thought okay another game is
calming down i mean i cannot be worse at
all i'm probably just better so
you know i was just happy to share my
results at this point but it was not
always the case in norway actually
sometimes i shot my views when my
position was
dubious or even almost lost so
but yeah
i was just in a good mood and what and
at some point it was not working because
they couldn't open the door
maybe you had too much to confess
but they managed
before was like ladies
great
just one quick final thought five wins
in the first round two black two wins
with the black pieces
what's going on
well i mean we were giving funds a bit a
bit of entertainment i'm not sure it was
planned for
for everyone but
in general it's great
to see fighting chess that's what
we're here to
to to do yeah in general i mean we're
not here to
to play some stupid rules i mean it will
happen of course in this kind of
tournament it
might always happen but
i mean
a one like this shows that
we're definitely not here to
to do some stupid draws well we
appreciate that and we like the way you
described yours as well as long as you
keep up the fighting chest uh great win
for you and best of luck in the rest of
the games okay thank you maxine vashila
grav off to a fine start at the expense
of wesley so but certainly a fantastic
beginning to the sing field cup
and ask for more could regen i mean i
feel like we're being spoiled
right out of the gate i mean wow
and i like the way mvl described it that
such a round really goes to show that
the players came they understood that
they're getting
defeated in the best conditions that
they possibly could ask for and they
want to respond by performing very well
well that's a great quote for the grand
chess tour indeed and as we wait for
some other um
interviews
let's take a couple tweets chris byrd
our international arbiter here is uh
is saying that he doesn't think that
we're gonna see another round like this
with five decisive results over in just
four hours right well the best we could
possibly do is match it we certainly
couldn't beat it that's right so so
those of you who came out to watch these
games live at the central west end we're
going to have a little bit more time to
check out
the uh the bars and restaurants and
coffee shops in this beautiful
neighborhood exactly
um jonathan manley
is quoting from i think his own
magazine king pain right that uh
an interview with grisha that my time
management is a pathology that can't be
cured
so you know what they say if you don't
want to be saved you can't be saved
right first you've got to recognize
you've got a problem and a shout out to
jonathan manley love kingpin always have
30 years i've been enjoying that
magazine is really a lot of fun well the
thing is maybe grisha didn't see that
great of a need to cure this pathology
with the traditional time controls with
30 seconds yes or traditional increments
kind of helped him
get over it right because you always
have 30 seconds but when it's left in
his own hands
it's uh
glycerin nitroglycerin
well we're waiting for our final
interviews here let's take a look at the
results after round one as i pointed out
because i knew any could take it like
he's tied for fifth right another way to
put that is tied for first through fifth
um we've got uh oh anish
and maxine bashir
we've got
nakamura
torpolav and
um
what am i missing i'm trying to erode on
all of the five points tomorrow the
games are going to be gear reversal
rasher legrob versus ronyon karana vs
carlson oh that's a big matchup you
wouldn't expect them both to have zero
points well and then um also a huge
matchup for hollywood versus nakamura so
followed with the white pieces um and
both of those the playing grade and um
number two and three in the world
meanwhile uh alexander grishouk and
bishyananda are also gonna be playing
tomorrow so wow i will every new round
is going to bring marquee matchups that
just goes without saying but it's just
so rare to see the situation where you
know half the field has lost half the
field has won and that'll just make it
tomorrow bloodier so i'm looking forward
to it so with no further ado we've got a
world champion magnus carlson with
maurice ashley
with the world's number one player
magnus carlson after a difficult loss
magnus uh this game was was chaotic it
was crazy
but at some point it seemed like you
were okay and then you did a couple of
things and your game went sour what
happened
uh well first of all um i made a
kind of strange decision already in the
opening because i think
well first of all g5 is a very
interesting move i couldn't find a
clear way for why to play after that
and then i
i couldn't decide whether to go for the
normal option or to
sacrifice
the peace which i did uh
but i suspected that it might not be
good but i thought i wouldn't be
much worse in in the worst case but
still i i should have just gone for the
more normal option playing knight c3 and
then and then d4 with with uh at least a
normal game uh
but then
why did you go for the piece hypervised
well
i wasn't completely sure if he analyzed
everything if you remembered
if you remembered it and
uh
and so i was also taking my opponent's
style into a question a bit because it
seemed that um it wouldn't be
comfortable defending these uh kind of
positions but
i think he navigated it okay and then at
some point
i needed to
to do something
well at some point i just needed to play
more solidly to
accept that i was not better by any
means and
i think i could still be perfectly fine
with them i just missed a couple of his
moves and i think even in the
end game i could have
had
chances to resist if i'd
played better but i just
made a couple of stupid blunders and and
and
he
yeah he
took it home quite easily is it a
question of form when this happens to
you i mean you've been extremely
consistent over the last several years
norway you didn't play well and now the
first round here is it is something just
when when it doesn't come out the
fingertips the right way
what's happening yeah it's it's just uh
it's a bit of the same uh
i um
at some point i i just make a move and i
realize immediately afterwards that it's
a blunder like today uh
when
when uh he when i he
when i took the pawn in h7 for instance
i don't know if i could have done
something differently but i immediately
that after that i saw queen d7 that this
plan was not queen g4 as i thought but
queen h3 which makes a huge uh
difference so that was just
i don't know it's
it's not very good
it's not a good feeling to
oh to play
yeah to not not play well and
it was also
a
problem of not playing practically today
because i knew
after i played this move knight a3 which
i spent quite a lot of time on
i really knew that i was going to
sacrifice a piece no matter
i mean i knew that there was really
uh at least in my mind no way back so i
should have played it
more quickly to have more time at
critical junctures later is there a
chance that maybe you remember what
happened in norway in round one and now
you face the same opponent and for you
it was like
go after him as opposed to play more
solidly and just play play the game
i was trying to play a solid line today
but then he played g5 and that's sort of
turned the
game around a bit uh so i've i felt that
after g5 yeah then i could still have
played more normal cultivation
continuation which i should have done
but
i mean
at least i wasn't outplayed in in norway
and today i just lost fair fair and
square i wasn't
good enough and
he just navigated the complications a
lot better than i did
well thanks so much for your candid
response and uh we wish you the best of
luck in the best of forum in the rest of
the games yeah thank you
magnus carlson world champion after a
tough loss
we'll see how he bounces back guys
thank you maurice
thank you
and uh we do have uh some tweets
actually from gary kasparov um he uh
predicted magnus carlsen as a favorite
in this tournament as today and today he
also has been watching the games and he
uh said a couple of things first he said
good thing we have some top chests to
watch at the sinkhole cup
because the u.s political shows are
still focused on clowns
tune in to us because you know this is
this is just pure pure beauty
pure
fight pure artistry um no need to really
tune into politics for a few more months
right
and
he also said that uh
it was a great day for fighting chess in
st louis and pointed out that if you
provide great conditions for the great
players you often get great battles
that's true and i just want to add
something else to all of this and it
really really hit me yesterday
during the autograph session there's
nothing like a packed house that really
gets the juices flowing whether you're
an athlete whether you're a musician
whether you're a chess grandmaster you
really respond to the audience of the
fans and so real shout out to all of
those people who've traveled from
all over the united states and from
other countries to joining us uh you
really encouraged the players very much
and you made the right decision
and you made the right decision i want
to be here right now and we do have the
man of the hour vessel tovalav he won
the first leg of the grand chess tour
and is off to another great start
beating the world champion in round one
with grand master vasily topolov making
his bulgarian fans and his fans all
around the world proud first of all
congratulations on your victory today
thank you so
you know it's not easy to beat magnus
carlsen two games in a row it's not easy
to beat him two blocks in a row
you are the leader of the grand chess
tour how did you feel about your play
today uh uh today i i think it was okay
i mean
uh re regarding the first win i had well
it's i shouldn't really count it but
you know
for the beginning it's very good i mean
i'm
i'm surprised because i have some small
problems with my thought and don't
really feel great
but well
you know it happens
i think i'm playing a decent game maybe
not always the best moves but it was
okay and
we had this idea at the beginning were
pushing the pawn
but of course i couldn't remember
anything and then over the board uh
after two moves i think i was okay and
and finally uh you know suddenly magnus
he sacrificed a piece which was a
surprise for me because maybe he didn't
like his position were you shocked when
you saw the sacrifice happening because
well it's moved ten it's around ten and
uh somehow it's not what white's
supposed to do you know uh
uh on move ten like fighting for
advantage but okay he was pissed down
and already fighting for
equality maybe but it was very sharp
still were you surprised uh
it looked like maybe he might have some
chances and then he played this movie e5
allowed this great maneuver queen c6
queen g6 and suddenly you were just it
just look like you were in control of
the game
yeah i believe black was always okay but
uh i was not completely clear if was
my advantage was so big you know so and
then in his time trouble he
he allowed me to do everything more or
less
again he could have defended better now
we saw a lot of time trouble in this
round it looks like everybody was in
time pressure
virtually except the aronian game and
also we saw victories everywhere five
wins two with black what's accounting
for this kind of fighting chess in your
opinion
well okay it's just a first round also
but uh you know even for me as a
professional i i like to watch this kind
of games i mean
i've seen
amazing games and still i like
to to see this kind of chess so you
think that it's the organizers or making
sure that draws or is it players is it
conditions what's contributing to it i
guess everybody wants to show his best
and not to play safely and you know
sometimes this happens it doesn't mean
it will be like this for for the rest of
the rounds
but it's very good start someone asked
me this question as a matter of fact are
you seeing a shift in the attitude of
chess players at the top trying to win
uh the way the way kasparov would try to
win his tournaments uh just dominate uh
you know it seems like there's been a
shift in style for some reason that i'm
not sure about myself that the the
players are playing for victories more
and more in tournaments like no easy
draws
usually at all
well i would say it was the my attitude
and i believe magnus's as well is that
we just don't think about draw just make
a move and that's uh several of the
players here they have this i i think
hikar is always like this and but in
general uh it is through the last 10 10
years more or less since the sylvia
invented the sofia rules even if it's
not
in the rules you know uh
players i i i believe they understand
they have to fight well we appreciate
as i said kasparov yourself as one of
the leading fighters and all the other
players playing this kind of chess and
congratulations on winning your game
today and best of luck in the rest of
your games thank you vasilye topolov in
first place well not so fast not clear
first but certainly a great way to start
his time here at the singh field cup all
right
that's right
yeah you've always got to look at the
negative right
and we got a couple other uh
tweets yeah we got a couple other
jokesters on uh on twitter
um john gustafson said he's tired of all
these lifeless gm draws at the same
field cop absolutely shout out to gusty
uh
we were together in norway and it was
wonderful watching him uh do that so
yeah he's a very funny guy so
we'll be on the lookout for more uh
more uh humorous streets from him and
we've also got grandmaster nigel short
chiming in um he said that magnus carlos
and topalov is headed for a dull draw
that's what happens when two guys play
chicken chats
so
again everybody
everybody is so excited by how crazy
this is that well i'm telling you jen i
felt like i've been waiting for this
tournament for a month i was so excited
about it and it's fulfilled everything
in round one that i could have possibly
expected that's right and we've got a
final thought from grandmaster maurice
ashley on round one of the sink field
cup
well what more could you ask for such a
fabulous finish of to a first round five
victories
not just because you got the white
pieces black won a couple of games as
well just a scintillating beginning and
it's great to see the change that has
happened in modern chess before you
might have seen a few quick draws but
not anymore as a vasily toppolov
mentioned with this sofia real change
his organizers wanted to see more
fighting chess and also a trend that
definitely i think began with kasparov
topalov has been a great fighter all his
career and now you have a world champion
in magnus carlson who wants to win every
game draws don't seem to matter to him
and you have players like nakamura geary
all the young players maxine vashila
grav they want to see victories too and
so today's round is all we could ask for
here and i can't even imagine we only
played five games and we're already so
excited with lots more chess to play
here at the sink field cup i can't wait
for round two guys thank you
so you don't want to miss this the
sinkfield cup is going to be a really
thrilling tournament tomorrow of course
carolina and carlson are playing top
club and nakamura it's going to be a
huge round join us tomorrow at 1 50
eastern time and that's 12 50 here in st
louis
we look forward to
you listening
bye guys
you